hello everyone and welcome to the april
2021 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and we're once again in the format
where we're getting way too many
questions for the ama for those of you
who don't know
questions are asked by patreon
supporters so you can go to patreon.com
sean m carroll and if you want to
support mindscape that's always a good
thing and some
fraction of the people who support on
patreon like to ask questions so we have
the monthly ama
there are too many questions for me to
really feasibly answer
uh all of them or even almost all of
them so i'm trying these days to go
through
pick out some group some together and so
forth and look
it breaks my heart honestly like i would
like to answer all these questions
um but i have to pick and choose and
what i want to emphasize
is it's not you it's me if i'm not
answering your question
it's not that the questions aren't good
really like
the questions are all good i could try
to answer any of them but
what i'm trying to do when i'm picking
questions to answer is
pick the questions that i have something
interesting to say about
so it's not only useful for the asker
but also
for the people who are listening
hopefully people listen to the content
here and get something out of it
so either it's a perfectly good question
that i'm just not inspired to say
anything interesting about
or it's a perfectly good question that
someone else could answer or you know
you could google or wikipedia or
whatever
those are not the questions i'm going to
answer um and in addition of course as i
say
in the call for questions i'm not going
to do any work to answer these questions
so if it's like read this person's
theory and tell me what you think that's
never gonna
happen sorry about that uh you know
again i would like to
in a world of infinite resources or
multiple copies of myself that i could
then talk to
and get information from i'd be able to
do that in the version of many worlds in
which we actually live
i don't get to talk to the other selves
that are doing all this work out there
so they're kind of useless
anyway having said all that lots of good
questions today so
let's go
i wanted to start with this news report
that we recently had that the large
hadron collider in particular the
lhcb experiment at cern
has an anomaly uh it has a result
that does not exactly fit into the
standard model of particle physics and a
couple people asked about
it uh joy callback maxime alexandrovich
michael rinaldi all asked different
questions about it um
and i don't want to go into too much
detail about it because i think that
i can probably use it as a jumping off
point for either
for talking to someone maybe just
talking to myself as a solo episode but
for digging in deeply
into related issues about the standard
model and how it works and what we
expect from it things like that i'm not
sure that i'm gonna do that
but it's a prospect so rather than
spending half an hour 20 minutes
explaining it here
let me just note that i'll give you the
30-second version here
what they found is that there's a
certain decay of a certain kind of quark
the bottom quark
joy asked what what happened to the
beauty quark didn't we used to call it
the beauty quark
um you know early in the days when you
either hypothesize or discover a new
particle
people will try to name it there's some
kind of collective intelligence action
that goes on and you decide
what to pick so the the third generation
of quarks some people wanted to call
them
truth and beauty other people want to
call them top and bottom
and the less evocative names won i
wasn't there
for that discussion so i'm not exactly
sure why they chose that but there you
go
anyway the prediction of the standard
model is that to a very good
approximation
the bottom quark should couple the same
to things like electrons and muons
um that's basically because the coupling
is through things like w
and z bosons and those coupled exactly
the same
but you could imagine that if there was
a new particle
that coupled to the bottom quark and two
electrons and muons
then the decay of the bottom quark into
electrons or mu ones would be a little
bit
different right a different a ratio that
was not quite one
of the number of electrons produced to
the number of muons produced and that
is apparently what they are seeing so
the question is
is it real or will it go away it is a
three sigma
event if you're if you're familiar with
that uh
statistical nomenclature which means you
know it's worth paying attention to but
we don't know if it's going to survive
or not so i always
preach patience in these cases it would
be easy to explain
if it were real easy in terms of we
would need to introduce new physics
to explain it but it's not hard to
invent versions of new physics that
would do the job you just need a
particle
that a virtual particle inside the
finemen diagram as it were
that would couple to bottom quarks and
differently
to up to um muons and electrons
you know the higgs boson does that i
think boson is an example
in this particular decay the higgs boson
just plays a very very tiny role
but if there's a particle that's more
important to affecting that then that'll
be really really interesting
in fact the the bad thing is there are
too many ways to explain it so if it's
just that one little fact even if it
becomes true
you don't then get to say oh it's
supersymmetry or oh it's grand
unification or oh it's whatever because
there's
more than one way of doing it so i would
say hold on
try to collect more data see where
things are going
douglas albrecht asks have you or others
speculated what might be
emerging properties at much larger
distances and time scales than we are
accustomed to considering
is there a reason not to think that
there might be radically different
emergent phenomena if we were somehow
able to appreciate our universe from
this kind of perspective
so if i understand correctly what you're
saying is if i understand it which i'm
not sure
but uh what we know is that you know
we're made of atoms and things like that
and these atoms come together
to make molecules and cells and organs
and bodies
and then the bodies come together to
make groups and societies and
civilizations and so
as you go to bigger and bigger levels
you get different kinds of emergent
descriptions of what's going on
and the question is could we imagine
going to bigger and bigger
levels right much bigger than planets or
people or maybe galaxies
um well i actually think the answer is
no here i mean it's a very good question
to ask it's perfectly reasonable
thing to wonder i suspect the answer is
no
for the following reasons number one we
know a little bit about things on the
scale of
galaxies right and you know galaxies in
the universe
are pretty far apart from each other um
in a cluster of galaxies they can be
very nearby and they bump into each
other all the time
the milky way is going to bump into
andromeda but individual galaxies out in
the field
are far away from each other and don't
bump into each other and clusters
generally don't bump into each other
so galaxies just don't interact that
much right i mean part of
getting an emergent phenomenon is that
not only you're on a big length scale
but the little individual pieces of
which you're made
are constantly interacting right are
constantly bumping into each other
so rather than describing them as just
individual pieces
occasionally interacting there's some
average behavior
that can emerge when the individual
pieces only occasionally interact that
doesn't become a useful way of talking
and the other thing is uh on very large
scales much larger than
galaxies or the universe the universe
just not that old
right you know we have the big bang 14
billion years ago
and the visible universe is some tens of
billions of light years
across which means uh which by the way
those two numbers are not the same the
size of the visible universe is not
exactly the age of the universe
in light years because in years because
um
the universe is expanding and there's a
complicated interaction there going on
but roughly speaking order of magnitude
the size of the visible universe in
light years is the same as the age of
the universe measured in years
which means that on scales larger than
the observable universe
there's been literally no interaction
there's not been enough time for things
to interact
very often and there won't be you know
the universe is accelerating so
the things that have not yet interacted
that are on cosmological distances from
each other will never
interact roughly speaking with each
other um
so they're not there's no chance there's
no opportunity
for these things to come together and be
described in an interesting way
as an emergent phenomenon that's my
that's my take on it
and i hope that i'm answering the
question you're actually asking
adrian says you strike me as someone
with a special talent for expressing
even controversial ideas in a very
diplomatic and respectful manner
it's probably easier when debating
intellectuals but do you have any tips
for someone who has trouble staying calm
and not getting angry when debating
let's say
a close family member with some rather
non-standard ideas about epidemiology
and virology
well um thank you for the compliment
uh of having the talent for expressing
even controversial ideas
you know i i don't have any simple uh
basic rules for these kind of situation
i think
the first thing to ask yourself is
what kind of situation are you actually
in look
sometimes people don't want to be
reasoned with right some people are just
not
in it for an intellectual debate some
people are not open-minded
about certain beliefs that they have
either those particular beliefs or those
particular people
more um more generally and in that case
save your breath don't waste your effort
right
um i one of the things that makes me
able to talk to people
who with whom i disagree is that the
people who i
choose to talk to are people who can be
talked to
right people who can be reasoned with
people who are saying well i think this
but let's talk about it let's you know
let's
actually reason i'm willing to listen to
what you have to say and
you know i'm too old to just sort of
debate people
who i don't agree with um you know as i
said before for the podcast
uh i specifically will occasionally
bring people on who i disagree with
and but only if i think that their ideas
are somehow worth contemplating
i think it's possible to disagree with
someone and yet say that their ideas are
not worthless right
we have to we have to admit that we
could sometimes be wrong if you're going
to ask your interlocutor or your
partner to admit that they could be
wrong you gotta admit that maybe you
could be wrong also
so the people i bring onto mindscape are
ones who i think we can all learn from
or at least provoke interesting ideas in
our head whether i agree with them
or not i will and have of course
done formal debates with people i deeply
disagree with
but they're really i'm not trying to
convince that person that they're wrong
they're you know up there on stage
making a performative act in whatever
they believe
i'm trying to reach the audience right
when i debated william lane craig
there were a lot of people in the
audience who were you know young people
who might have been religious who had
just never heard
the perspective of an atheist who was a
reasonable person with a
some answers to the questions that might
have been bugging them so
the purpose of a debate like that is not
for me
to win the debate or to convince the
other person is to
put some ideas into the head of audience
members who might not have otherwise
heard them
now family members are a different
issue right because on the one hand you
kind of have to deal with them and you
want to you know they're in your family
you care about them
um on the other hand they might not be
rational or reasonable
and they're you know i don't have advice
about how to
not get angry i think it's good not to
get angry i mean you know that kind of
advice should come from
i don't know either a psychologist or a
zen master or somebody like that but
uh i i agree that you should aim you
should aspire to not getting angry it
never helps
to get angry with people when you're
just debating about something
um you know there are people who like to
debate
not because they have irrational beliefs
that they were going to stick to but
because they have no beliefs at all they
just like to win debates
those people to me are just as annoying
as the ones who
have irrational beliefs that they're
going to stick to like i'm not
interested
in that my my participating in debates
is always about
raising the overall understanding of the
world on the part of either the people
participating or the people listening
it's never about
showing off some intellectual chops or
anything like that
so if you find those people who are just
like like to debate then you know again
i would just
choose to do other things um as far as
your family members you have to remember
that
you do care about them and sometimes
even though you care about them they're
going to be wrong and you're going to
live with that right
you know forget about people with
opinions about vaccines or something
like that
this very often happens when you have
very elderly relatives whether it's
parents or grandparents or whatever
and you know they want to live their
lives in a certain way
and you don't agree like you think that
they're taking risks or something like
that
you know they're they're not using their
remaining days in the best way possible
and my attitude there is that if someone
is not endangering others like i don't
want people who can't drive anymore
to be driving right that's that would be
bad but if people choose to you know
live a lifestyle when they're older that
is maybe a little bit riskier
to their health but makes them much much
happier
let them do it that's my philosophy i
think the the motto is
autonomy is more important than
rationality when you get to that point
in your life you know when you're to the
point in your life where you don't have
many years left
let people live their lives obviously if
they're suffering from dementia or
something like that or like i said if
they're a danger to others that would
not count but
if people are relatively in control of
their faculties
i like to let people make choices that
are their choices even if it's not the
choices i would wish
they could make i know that's not the
question you asked but i sort of
got rambling there sorry about that
brian davis says
if dark matter did not exist or any of
its observed effects do you think that
the resulting conditions
could have allowed would have allowed
for life to emerge
so this is sneakily a really good
question i don't know brian if you know
uh the story here but for life as we
know it right now
here on earth dark matter plays zero
role okay if all the dark matter and the
universe disappeared right now you and i
would not even notice it would certainly
not affect our lives
but it is possible that dark matter
played a role
in creating the first generation of
stars
i mean we know that dark matter create
had a role creating the first generation
of galaxies right
but dark matter doesn't like to clump
together as i've said before
on the podcast so dark matter doesn't
clump together into star-like
things but yet people have suggested
that maybe
the combination of dark matter dynamics
and ordinary matter dynamics
in the early universe helped create
really big stars
in the very first generation and then
those would explode and create heavier
elements and lead to other star
formation down the line
etc so i don't know what the answer is
to your question but it is conceivable
to me that without dark matter
life the kinds of stars and planets that
support life would at least be much more
rare
in the universe than they are i don't
know if it'll be impossible
usually it's not impossible we have a
big universe out there right so
maybe uh without dark matter stars would
be much less
common but they would still be there
occasionally in the universe
okay i'm going to group together four
different questions let me just ask them
all
explicitly here hopefully the theme will
come through
chris rogers says is gravity a force
eugene novikov says we lay people are
taught using trampoline analogies that
gravity is the manifestation of the
curvature of space-time itself
that seems conceptually very different
from the idea that gravity is a force
mediated by an elementary particle
called the graviton how should we think
about the relationship between these
ideas
sean atkinson says i understand we are
confident that gravity must be
communicated by
via an additional quantum particle
referred to as the gravitino
and it's just a matter of discovery but
i've also heard on multiple occasions
that gravity is not so much a regular
force
but rather how space time is curved
these explanations have always felt like
some kind of contradiction am i missing
something
and anonymous says i have a question
about what it means for space to be
curved if i put a cantaloupe on an empty
cereal box
the that's a very specific analogy by
the way that
if you put a cantaloupe on an empty
cereal box the surface of the box will
bend inward and curve
but i could still think of the box as
curved with respect to rigid
three-dimensional coordinates
can space be thought of as a curved
medium that's completely filling true
empty space like a bunched up scarf
inside his shoebox or is there just the
scarf okay
so i hope you get the theme of what is
gravity and what is curvature of
space-time is it really a force is it
really a particle
of these four questions it's interesting
you know maybe someone could do
uh some deep learning analysis of the
ama questions and why certain topics
pop up multiple times something in the
air i don't know someone out there
talking about
curve space time and is gravity of force
so
you know i when i was young when i was
your age
i was pretty doctrinaire about saying
gravity is not a force
once you understand general relativity
and the reason for saying that
is that einstein's great insight in
general relativity is that
unlike so he already had the insight he
didn't have the insight but
due to special relativity uh henry
minkowski
einstein's former teacher had the
insight that we should
dissolve space and time separately and
make them into one four-dimensional
space-time
einstein was reluctant to accept that
but eventually accepted it and said you
know what
gravity is not a force propagating on
top of space-time
it is a feature of space-time itself
okay
so there's a way of thinking that says
we should separate out
forces that live within space-time like
electromagnetism and the nuclear forces
from features of space-time itself and
this helps understand
the principle of equivalence if you're
in a small region of space you can't
even tell
whether you're in a gravitational field
or not space time i should say
whereas you can tell if there's an
electric field or if there's a magnetic
field or something like that
um so that's the justification for
saying that you shouldn't think of
gravity as a force but you know i'm
in my old age and my dotage i'm much
more
open-minded about these things you know
sure gravity is a force
in some sense when i drop this pen that
is right in front of me if i drop it
there you heard it drop it fell on the
desk
i can describe that as the force of
gravity pulling on the pen that's not a
bad or illegal move to make so
the point is that the idea of a force
or any idea like force or energy or
acceleration or any of these things
these are not pre-theoretic ideas
okay all these ideas are words that we
invent in the context of some
understanding
of the world and maybe within some sort
of way of talking they're useful words
some other way of talking they're not
the best
way we have of describing gravity in the
macroscopic classical world
is as the curvature of space-time if you
want to therefore say it's not a force
it's not a particle it's the curvature
of space-time
fine but there could very well be other
circumstances
either more limited or more specialized
or or more general
where there's another way of talking
about gravity so you can also here in
the room where the newtonian
approximation is really really good
talking about gravity as a force is
perfectly fine
talking about as a it as a particle
being exchanged that's the exchange of a
graviton
is also perfectly fine it's exactly
analogous
to how we talk about electromagnetism
and electromagnetic fields
or we talk about the exchange of
individual gravitons
so one of the questions called it the
gravity no that's not right
that is definitely a mistake so it's
called the graviton the particle of
gravity
um gravitino would be the supersymmetric
partner of the graviton if such a thing
exists we've never discovered either one
so gravitinos are truly hypothetical
gravitons
almost certainly exist i say almost
certainly because quantum mechanics is
correct and gravity is correct and if
you believe both of those things there's
going to be a particle called the
graviton
it's just too weak too weakly
interacting with us for us to ever
realistically discover individual
gravitons unless
something crazy happens like gravity
becomes much stronger at higher energies
which is possible but not very
likely these days so it's not that it's
a contradiction this is two different
languages
for describing the same thing now one
more piece
of uh one more piece of physics i need
to say and i forget
i might have erased my mistake the uh
the
question about this but um when you or
it might be later so i might be
answering it earlier
than necessary here but here is a
question you could reasonably have um
when you draw like a finding diagram and
you imagine two electrons okay
and their electrons approach each other
and they exchange a photon and they
scatter
okay that makes sense like it makes
sense from an intuitive point of view
you know if you have two people on a
boat on two different boats and they're
sort of moving through
the lake and it's not very windy or
anything and one of them throws a
medicine ball to the other the the one
who throws you know there's some
momentum
imparted to that medicine ball and it
pushes them in the other direction
and likewise the one who catches it is
pushed in the other direction so
by the exchange of the medicine ball the
two little boats the two little canoes
are pushed apart
that makes sense much like two little
electrons are pushed apart by the
electromagnetic force
but if you have an electron and a
positron or if you have
two objects exchanging gravitons they're
not pushed apart they're pulled together
how in the world do you pull something
together by throwing something back and
forth right it seems like the only thing
you could do is push yourself apart
the secret is that virtual particles
i discussed this in the biggest ideas in
the universe videos virtual particles
don't necessarily
have a positive value of the momentum
you can throw a virtual particle from
one
particle to another one with a negative
momentum
when you throw a particle with a
negative momentum in some direction you
start moving in that
direction to conserve momentum right and
this is all the math all works out it's
a little bit counterintuitive but trust
me on that i just want to
let you know there's a little bit of
counter-intuitive goings-on to help
explain how
you can get both attractive and
repulsive forces uh
from exchange of particles in finding
diagrams
and finally to the you know the uh space
versus the scarf
question so what what i take it here is
being asked is
when we visualize curved spaces or
surfaces
we inevitably do it as a three as a
two-dimensional surface
being bent you know like the rubber
sheet with the bowling ball on it
embedded in three-dimensional space that
we live right and that is
entirely a feature of our
visualization capacities that is not a
feature
of nature so we do not think that
because our three-dimensional space
or our four-dimensional space-time is
curved that it therefore
must be embedded in a higher dimensional
flat spacetime this was
really the insight that came from the
1800s
when gauss and riemann and others
discovered how to do
intrinsic geometry rather than extrinsic
geometry
the extrinsic geometry is talking about
how you're embedded in a bigger space
intrinsic geometry is just what's going
on to you
internally in the space that you're in
and you don't need to be embedded in any
bigger space you can ask questions like
if i start two photons off and they're
initially parallel
do they converge on each other do they
get deflected away from each other do
they twist
in some direction these are all askable
questions and they're all answerable
questions from the perspective of
someone inside
the space you don't need to be embedded
in a bigger space outside
and that's kind of what we do when we do
general relativity that's essentially
the kind of thought experiment that
we're doing
in some more technically relevant way to
some real physical situation so we don't
need
anything outside when the universe is
expanding when it's curved etc
that does not imply there's any other
universe that we are
that it is part of or that we're
embedded in oh yeah it's right here it's
a very next question should have been
grouped into there it's from thomas
prunty he says
in last month's ama he talked about how
a classical field arises from a
collection of bosons
how then would you describe the
corresponding force in terms of
particles for example how does the
classical electrostatic force arise from
exchange of photons
what makes it attractive or repulsive so
there you go that's what it is you know
the details are in things like
the charge of the particles right and
that
affects the value of the finemen diagram
that you calculate
and uh beyond that at the level of this
ama with no pictures or no equations i'm
gonna have to say trust me on that
uh but it all does fit together it's all
you know you think of
tiny little fluctuations in fields as
corresponding to particles
and big coherent bending or
expectation values of fields as
corresponding to classical
fields that you would notice in your
everyday life okay gerald swann
says regarding the fermi paradox do you
think it's possible that other
technological civilizations exist but
interstellar travel is simply
intractable engineering
no i don't really think that that's a
very viable solution i don't think that
interstellar travel is intractable
engineering i mean
look even we puny humans have sent
spacecraft outside the solar system
right the voyagers the pioneers etc
now they're moving very very slowly but
we really are very backward right now
compared to where we could imagine being
in terms of rocket propulsion etc the
other thing you have to keep in mind is
that you know everyone worries about the
speed of light it takes years or tens of
years or hundreds of years to travel
from
our solar system to other solar systems
at reasonable fractions of the speed of
light
that sounds like a long time what if it
takes 10 000 years to get to
the star you want to get to well that's
fine
you won't survive right um but number
one maybe you will survive because maybe
we'll
uh solve longevity of human beings maybe
we'll be able to solve aging that's a
possibility
number two there could be cryogenic
suspended animation number three we
could just send robots
most importantly ten thousand years is
nothing
compared to the lifespan of a planet or
a star or the galaxy
right so i don't see any reason why you
should think that
interstellar travel is so hard that no
one has left
their solar system that maybe it's true
i mean anything's possible i don't know
for sure but that would not be the way
that i would bet
justin bailey says would you summarize
how you avoid the boltzmann brain
paradox in your view of the universe
you know i don't have a view of the
universe once and for all i
as a theoretical physicist investigate
different scenarios right we propose
different hypotheses
and we uh try to figure out which ones
are the best
fit to the data so i'm not sure if you
mean specifically
i did with jennifer chen proposed in in
2004
a view of the multiverse where baby
universes were created from quantum
fluctuations
in empty space and those baby universes
grew up
into big uh inflationary universes
so in that particular situation
the reason why you avoid the boltzmann
brain problem
is because you create boltzmann brains
very plausibly you also create universes
and those universes grow up and create
lots of ordinary observers
and the point is you can show that you
create
more universes than brains a universe
that sounds like a lot to create sounds
like harder to create but in fact this
is the miracle of inflationary cosmology
and general relativity for that matter
creating a universe is not that hard
universes can start really really tiny
okay near the planck scale
they can inflate upward to whatever size
you want
and the total amount of energy cost to
create a universe is zero
that's a tricky thing because there's
both negative energy and positive energy
and
general
relativity much like much like but not
exactly like the negative and positive
momenta
inside finding diagrams that we just
talked about so the point of
the point is that if you just calculate
the chance that you will get a random
quantum fluctuation
into a brain or a living being that is
lower than the chance you'll get a
random quantum fluctuation
into a little bubble ready to make a
whole universe
and every bubble corresponds maybe to
billions or trillions or quadrillions of
ordinary observers
so the hope is that to the extent that
it's possible to compare them you make
more ordinary observers than boltzmann
brains
now i don't necessarily think that
scenario is right i think it's possibly
right
i think there's a credence that you
should have that something like that is
on the right track but we don't know
for sure certainly so i'm not sure if
that's the right way
that the universe avoids the boltzmann
brain problem i think it is roughly
speaking to possibilities
um the boltzmann brain problem arises
when you have a universe
that lasts forever and randomly
fluctuates
okay so there could be random
fluctuations then years more likely
overall
to get uh if you if you have a finite
number of things that can happen in the
universe
then small fluctuations away from
equilibrium will always be
more likely than large fluctuations
that's when you get the boltzmann brain
problem
when you have a finite number of things
that can happen and an
infinite amount of time for them to
happen in so that's why i said there's
roughly speaking two ways out
one way is have an infinite number of
things that can happen not just a finite
way
that's what we take advantage of in our
scenario
but the other way is to not let the
universe last forever have a universe
that really
not just within our observable universe
but overall lasts a finite time then
it's very very easy to have more
ordinary observers than boltzmann brains
which one is actually true i don't know
i don't know we're active we have to
think about that we have a long way to
go to really have confidence one way or
the other
pair magnuson says what are your
thoughts on the possibility and time
frame of a future technological
singularity
it seems to me like we are making very
fast technological progress in some
regards but in others we seem to have
picked most of low-hanging fruit and
progress is not obviously exponential
um yeah i have zero credence not quite
zero but almost zero
in a future technological singularity um
of course it depends on what you mean
but
i take it at face value that a
technological singularity
is really equivalent to um an
essentially infinite rate of progress
in technology and that is what people
have tried to argue for
but there's no way to quantify rate of
progress in technology
i mean there's no one way that captures
everything you can invent ways
but a lot of it has just been hand
waving honestly
and i think that besides just being hand
waving
and and ungrounded optimism
the other problem is that people take
you know exponentials
exponential growth curves and just
extrapolate them by the way you need
worse than exponential
not worse better than exponential to get
a singularity right an exponential is
not a singularity an exponential just
keeps growing forever
um a singularity is like one over x
as you approach x from the left uh it
goes to infinity in a finite
interval um that's what you would need
for a singularity and
and even if you had super exponential
growth
you could only have that for a little
time there's no guarantee whatsoever
that you have it forever there are
plenty of examples in nature
of you know yeast growth curves which
kind of look like bell curves where you
exponentially grow
but then you peak and you go back down
to zero that's a very plausible future
scenario
you also have sigmoid curves where you
grow for a while exponentially but then
you flatten off and are just flat for a
long time
in a new equilibrium you know if you go
back to one of my favorite mindscape
episodes with joe walston
uh about uh the environment and
urbanization
and we and we talked about the fact that
we could be in the midst
of a transition between two equilibria
um where one equilibrium has no
urbanization and no
technology right and so you know people
were just
animals just like everything else and
the earth went along perfectly fine
but then we discovered technology and we
began to exponentially
uh change our lives but it's possible
that we're just approaching a new
equilibrium where most people live in
cities
most of the earth is not urbanized at
all and there's no people living there
there's the rest of the ecosystem living
there
and we live happily in our cities and we
interact with the outside world but we
don't
ruin it and despoil it as we so often do
these days
like you imply in your question there
are some
areas in which we picked most of
low-hanging fruit i think that's
absolutely true
you know atoms are the smallest thing we
can make things out of i mean electrons
okay
electrons or nuclei etc but you can't
get smaller than that
technologically so once you reach the
point where you are manipulating
individual atoms and individual
particles
all future progress is made from
putting those basic pieces together in
more and more interesting ways
not in getting smaller in the
fundamental pieces from which you're
building your technology
there's plenty of room for improvement
um
but still there are some particular uh
what should i say
particular avenues of improvement that
are no longer open to us and that won't
be open to us
that doesn't mean that improvement stops
but it just means that you need to do it
in other directions right
uh and it's completely plausible to me
that you know we improve technology for
a while then we stop improving it
it's we're not almost there it's not
like we're going to happen the next 10
years
but if you think about the next 10 000
years that's completely plausible to me
sam says are you pleased with what the
sixers did or didn't do with the trade
deadline and have you spoken to daryl
about it
by which of course he means daryl mori
who's a recent mindscape guest
um i'm pretty pleased with what they did
actually you know for those of you who
have not been keeping track the sixers
were rumored to be
part of a blockbuster trade deal
with the toronto raptors to get kyle
lowry but it turns out
that they would have had to trade a lot
of their existing
players and future draft picks and they
didn't do it they thought it wasn't
worth it and i think that's
the correct choice um i did not speak to
daryl about it
uh you know the sixers did pick up
george hill who's a good you know second
choice i think good uh shooting point
guard who can play defense
um you know and the reason why i'm
asking this question is not because i
have anything especially insightful to
say about the sexers or that most of you
care about that but you know
i do think there's something to be said
about uh how much you bug people
and you know i take you know some people
who i have on the podcast or people who
i know
personally we hang out right we see at
conferences
or we see in other you know social
situations and other people i have on
the podcast
when i have you know wynton marsalis or
cornell west or daryl mori or seth
macfarlane i'm not buddies with these
people we got along really really well
for the podcast episode but
i'm not gonna you know constantly um
pester them with my opinions about their
job i think that that is you know part
of the bargain
uh is that you respect other people's
time
and space if the people are especially
really really busy you know working at a
high level in some particular profession
uh you know if we happen to meet up and
have a drink together
and you know chat then i'll i might do
that but
i'm not going to be dming daryl mori
with my opinions about the sixers trade
deadline
he deserves better than that what do i
know okay
he has not dm to me about his favorite
theories of dark matter either just so
you know
dragon sighted d says could you briefly
compare and contrast the work with you
and alan guth
on a two-headed arrow of time at the big
bang with neil turakin collaborators
cpt symmetrical theory it looks like
both posit basically two equal and
opposite universes resulting from the
big bang
are they compatible theories so the work
so here's the the bigger story here for
those of you who don't know
what this is referring to as i said in
2004
uh jennifer chen and i proposed this
very specific model with baby universes
and the motivation for that model was to
make realistic
the idea that there is an
infinite number of things that can
happen in the universe and an infant
amount of time for them to happen okay
um so i mean you can do that in a
trivial way have a particle have a
universe with three particles in it
and space is infinitely big and the
particles sort of you know come together
and they just
zoom off to infinity forever so in some
trivial sense that's the universe where
things are always changing because the
particles are always getting further and
further away
and what happens in a universe like that
is that
there will always be a moment you just
have three particles again they're not
for even forget about gravity okay just
three particles that are moving on
straight lines
three particles moving on straight lines
through the universe always have the
property that there was a moment when
they were closest
there's a single moment when they're
closest whatever else you're going to do
no matter what their specific
trajectories are
and in both the past and the future of
that moment
they're further apart so you can kind of
use this behavior
as a metaphor as an analogy for the
behavior of entropy
when you have many many many more
particles or more quantum degrees of
freedom or whatever
so the idea is that if time lasts
forever and you have a universe that can
always be
changing the generic behavior you expect
is that there is a moment of minimum
entropy
and entropy is increasing both to the
past of that moment and to the future of
that moment
so you're not tuning the fact that
entropy is increasing entropy is always
increasing
everywhere except for literally one
moment of time okay
the question is can you make it
realistic so what jenny chen and i try
to do is make it realistic with baby
universes and big bangs and stuff like
that
this leaves more conceptual questions
about how you
make predictions and how you tame the
infinities
in such a scenario so that's what alan
guth and i have been working on
um slowly in my apologies to alan and
the unlikely
uh case that he is listening to this
both allen and i
you know are very very interested in
this problem but we're the worst people
for getting things done so we've been
working on this for years
and just not quite finishing the project
but
it's very closely related to similar
work that julian barber did
with his collaborators on the janus
point he wrote a whole book about it
in you know some classical gravitational
theory having this behavior where
there's a moment
of minimum entropy and it increases to
the future in the past
so alan and i are looking at the you
know fundamental conceptual questions
here
julian and his collaborators had a
specific scenario which wasn't very
realistic but at least they could solve
all the equations
jenny and i had a specific scenario
where we don't have control
over the equation so we had to make
guesses and cross our fingers that's why
it's much more speculative
in contrast so neil turock and his
collaborators i'm sorry i forget the
collaborators names i didn't look it up
before doing this
they had a theory have a theory um and
by the way there's other people who
followed up
jenny and my ideas so stephen hawking
with jim hardell and thomas hertoghe
looked at bouncing or overall
symmetric cosmologies within their
uh wave function of the universe quantum
cosmology program so there's there's
other people who've done this kind of
thing
um and so neil turock and his friends
did a specific again a specific example
of this
where they had kind of a bounce at the
at the middle
of the history of the universe and the
universe expands and entropy grows in
both directions away from it
and it's symmetric under this particle
physics symmetry called cpt
charge parity time reversal symmetry and
their idea was you know not only are
they explaining
the big bang cosmology but somehow the
matter antimatter asymmetry
in the universe our universe has more
matter than anti-matter maybe on the
other side of the big bang there's more
anti-matter than matter
something like that so there's a huge
difference
between these actually so the the
similarity
is that if you go to the far past and
the far future
you get very similar looking cosmologies
where
entropy is increasing and you get an
error of time pointing in opposite
directions
but the difference is that they have a
very very very very specific
condition right there in the middle okay
so they're not saying this will happen
for any old
initial conditions they're picking
almost infinitely finely tuned
initial conditions to do that and again
other people have done
the same thing long ago uh anthony
iguire who is a
former mindscape guest he and steven
gratton wrote a paper about
a completely symmetric dissider
space-based cosmology they didn't try to
explain
bariogenesis or the matter antimatter
asymmetry but they did the general
relativity and got that cosmological
solution i think that was before my
paper with jenny
but the difference is they weren't
trying to explain the fine-tuning of the
early entropy and neither is neil
tarakin and his friends like
jen and i were specifically aimed at
trying to give a dynamical explanation
for the observed low entropy of our
early universe and by the way you know
i i think it's still true even though
the the scenario that jenny and i put
forward is extremely speculative
and involves a whole lots of leap a lot
of leaps of faith
um it works under those assumptions
right so
it's not cheating it's not putting in
it's not cooking in the answer it's not
fine-tuning anything
and i don't know any other theory that
does that still you know 15 years later
um so there's work to be done and either
we're right or someone else is right i
would like to know one way or the other
george sorobiza says as you know
light has zero mass and since everything
divided by zero and multiplied by zero
always gives zero gravity has to have a
very little or no effect on light
however light never chooses the shortest
path route instead it always chooses the
shortest
time route would it be reasonable to
state that when light encounters dense
galaxies it should take
less time for the light to go around the
dense galaxies
than through them so there's a couple
things i have to undo
here um everything divided by zero does
not always give zero
so you're not allowed to divide by zero
as a
blatant move you can take a limit of
dividing by a really tiny number
and sending that tiny number to zero and
usually you just say what you get is not
a number you get a singularity right but
there could be
special cases where things work out well
and you get a finite number but there's
absolutely no rule
that says when you divide by zero you
get zero just so you know that
uh it's also not true the gravity has
zero
to no effect on light this is one of
einstein's discoveries right in
newtonian gravity you think of the mass
of a particle as both its resistance to
a force
right is the amount of inertia it has f
equals ma the more massive it is the
more force you have to give to
accelerate the particle
but you also in newtonian mechanics
think of the mass as the
source of gravity the more mass the more
gravitational field it has and the more
it is affected by a gravitational field
but that's not what einstein says
okay einstein says you have the
principle of equivalence
einstein says that space and time are
curved
and that freely falling particles choose
shortest space-time intervals along the
paths on which they travel
so it is absolutely true that gravity
affects light it affects like quite a
bit
actually i mean if you go near a black
hole those pictures you see from black
holes or an interstellar
you see photons zooming around black
holes multiple times before they
escape having said all that the actual
question
there is a feature of
general relativity that in some sense
the time it takes light to travel near a
gravitational field
would be less than the time it takes to
sort of zoom around
the outside and be deflected so that it
is a way if what you're asking is
can we think about the actual motion of
photons and curve space time by using
something like the principle at least
time the answer is yes
now i'm saying all that in very vague
heavily footnoted
language because time measured by what
etcetera you have to like
figure out what your clocks are but
roughly speaking that's true so for
government work purposes
yeah that's fine rasmus keith nierbeck
says
are there any ways for amateurs to
contribute to physics in the sense of
citizen
science you know amateurs the point here
being there's a lot of citizen science
that people can do to help contribute to
science and things like
biology anthropology or whatever
paleontology
botany physics is harder and so
physics is harder it really is um for
a whole number of reasons and it depends
very much on the kind of physics you're
talking about
you know if you're talking about
theoretical physics you know creating
new theories of cosmology or fundamental
particles
then it's really really hard for the
basic reason that you need a lot of
background right you need to take
years worth of courses to get the
background necessary to do the work
now in this day and age you could do
that
right you could buy the books or you
could just take the online courses and
you could educate yourself
up uh gerard tuft the nobel prize
winning physicist has a website where he
goes through the whole curriculum
of what courses you need to take he's a
little bit overly enthusiastic maybe he
wants to train you up to be a nobel
prize winner but if you just want to
make some contribution it's less than
that but honestly you know even if you
did that
which is really hard to do but not
being around the community of other
physicists
not being in graduate school having
friends you could talk with about
problems and so forth
makes it really really hard to
contribute to that kind of theoretical
physics
at a at a useful level there are other
areas of physics
right there's more experimental areas
etc
it is conceivable to me that citizens
who are not professionals with less
training than a phd could contribute to
those areas but honestly i don't know
it's not my thing right so i'm not an
expert
once you move into astrophysics it
becomes more possible i mean there are
citizen science
projects that you know monitor the sky
for different things or do radio
telescope kind of
science again i am not an expert sorry
about that
but uh it is possible in principle
i think the overall lesson is that
citizen science is great and if you're
interested in that you should look into
it but
it would be a mistake to be too devoted
ahead of time
to what kind of science you want to do i
mean after all if
if if your interest is literally in
doing citizen science
rather than simply learning science
everyone is welcome to learn whatever
science they want but if you want to
contribute to it
then given that motivation you really
should take
into account where can you make the most
interesting contribution and that might
not be in physics so that would be my
not very helpful but hopefully correct
advice
thierry larue paquette says when we do
the double slit experiment to show the
wave particle property of an electron
how can we maintain the electron in the
superposition state
while its own gravity should interact
with the surroundings and then decohere
i'm going to combine this with the next
question which is martin coomber
saying something deeply hidden is one of
the few popular science books i was able
to read
and end however i struggle with the
concept of decoherence
in particular why doesn't everything
become entangled by extension to
everything else
and would this extended entanglement
happen at the speed of light so both of
these questions are about the process
of decoherence the idea being when you
have a quantum system that is in some
kind of superposition
when it interacts in a particular way
with the external world
it becomes entangled with that external
world and
that is going to lead to this phenomenon
decoherence decoherence
simply is a little quantum system in a
superposition becoming entangled with
its environment
so the important thing and i know this
is hard to get across at a popular level
of discussion but the important thing to
keep in mind here is that
decoherence happens because of
interactions
physical interactions you know governed
by the laws of physics nothing weird or
spooky
but not every interaction leads to
decoherence
decoherence happens specifically with
the kinds of interactions
that are affecting the quantum system
differently
depending on which part of the quantum
superposition it's in
okay so let's say that you have an
electron or some other particle
neutron electrically i keep i keep
saying electrons when i talk about
measuring the spin of particles
you shouldn't actually talk about
electrons because they're electrically
charged and
it's hard to measure their spin directly
neutral particles are easier because
they're not being affected by the stray
electromagnetic fields
anyway let's say we have a neutron we're
going to measure its spin okay
you can do that put it through a
magnetic field spin up will be deflected
one way spin down will be deflected the
other way
the point is that in the initial state
if the neutron starts in a superposition
of spin up and spin down
if i just take the neutron you know in a
box and i move it
i'm interacting with it right i'm moving
the neutron from one place to another
but i'm interacting with the spin up
part and the spin down part
in exactly the same way the fact that
i'm moving the center of mass of the
neutron
is completely irrelevant to the
different spin
parts of the wave function of the
electron so that's
not decoherence that is not becoming
entangled with the neutron it's just
moving it
it's interacting with it but not
becoming entangled
that's why you have to do all this work
to measure the spin
of the neutron by throwing it through a
distorted magnetic field and watching it
uh be deflected one way or the other and
then
detecting it on the other side you have
to
specifically interact with it in a way
that interacts
differently with the spin up part in the
spin down part that's what the magnetic
field
will do likewise with the electron going
through the double slit
it interacts with the slits but it does
not become
entangled with them in different ways
now you ask specifically thierry about
gravity and this becomes a subtle
question actually
you know um electrons or whatever
they're coupled to gravity
they're coupled to photons right
electromagnetism also
so if the electron passes through the
slits and
bumps into them with enough umph
it can shake off shake loose a few
gravitons or a few
photons for that matter and that could
lead to decoherence
so it becomes a quantitative question
and in fact you know
you don't need you need to shake it
pretty hard to decohere in that way so
the numbers
simply tell you that even though the
electron is
uh dispersed by the slits it goes
through diffracted
it's actually not becoming entangled
with them in any substantial way
philip lakashis says after reading your
lace
latest pre-print on mad dog of a
readianism i'm wondering what your
philosophical motivation for pursuing
this paradigm
is is it maybe some kinds of occam's
razor philosophy that the most simple
theory is the one that is most likely
true
or are there further reasons one might
feel that other approaches
uh are epic epistemologically less
promising approaches
so i think it's both um so what is what
philip is referring to is
i wrote a paper a couple years ago with
ash mead singh called mad dog
everettianism so everett
everybody in quantum mechanics says the
world is described by a wave function
that evolves with time according to the
schrodinger equation but
usually when people do physics
they not only say there's a wave
function but they tell you something
about the wave function
it's a function of position or momentum
or of quantum fields or whatever
and that gives you an enormous amount of
extra structure you can use to probe the
theory to describe it etc
the mad dog everettianism says
that wave function is just a vector in
hilbert space
okay it's not a function of anything
the idea that the wave function that the
state vector if you want to call it that
should be thought of as a wave function
of something
should be an emergent phenomenon in some
approximation
at a coarse grained level that's the mad
dog idea and so you
so in other words you're removing even
some of the very minimal ingredients
that have already in quantum mechanics
typically
lets itself uh helps itself to when
describing the world
and you say all you have is a vector
evolving according to the schrodinger
equation and everything else should be
emergent that's the idea
so it's the most minimal approach you
can have and so i recently wrote another
paper
um reality as a vector in hilbert space
you can find it and it is
kind of a restatement of that idea but
this one is more aimed at philosophers
it was a
an essay that i wrote for an invited uh
collection of essays on the fundamental
ontology of quantum mechanics
and so i rather than going through the
equations uh there were some equations
in there but mostly i
i sort of defended the approach because
it was for philosophers more than
physicists
and part of the motivation is exactly
like you say
occam's razor you know if you have
multiple theories that explain the same
phenomena the simplest one is a good
bet to put most of your credence on
until you know better
but also i just i think it's the natural
implication of being a ready in at all
you know like i try to make the point
that there's a big difference between
living in a hilbert space that is
infinite dimensional and finite
dimensional
if you are in an infinite dimensional
there's subtleties here that i can't go
into now
between there's different levels of
infinity countable and uncountable etc
okay
but in typical quantum field theory you
need to be given more information
than just the wave function you need to
be given what are the observables of
your theory
okay but i think that because of gravity
we don't have an infinite number
of dimensions in hilbert space and then
you're not given the observables the
observables are just all the observables
they're
automatic there's no extra information
being attached to your theory
and in that case i think you have no
choice but to take this mad dog of
reading approach so i think it's both
simpler and inevitable if you're going
to be ever writing at all in the real
world that would be my answer
george aston says could you take a guess
at what might be needed to be discovered
to get us one step closer to inertia
negation or dampening technology
as seen in star trek and could the
mechanisms behind inertia negation
potentially offer an alternative idea to
dark matter
for why spiral galaxies don't spin apart
um
no i don't think there is any such thing
as inertia negation or dampening and i
don't think there's any such technology
out there to be discovered
you know um in fact i did a twitter poll
the other day a few
months ago actually you know what when
hundreds of years have passed and
humanity is you know flying in
spaceships all the time
and they have nostalgia night and
they're looking at old science fiction
movies from the 20th and 21st centuries
what will be the most annoying thing to
them
the answer is clearly artificial gravity
because there's no way to make
artificial gravity except by spinning
something like that there's just no
known physics that would make that
happen
and furthermore things are much more
interesting when you take into account
the reality of the fact that you'd be in
free fall most of the time in a in a
spaceship or you'd be pushed around by
the acceleration okay those are the only
two choices
and that's kind of interesting and you
know it's narratively interesting it
does cost more money maybe to do the
special effects
but the idea that you know on star trek
we're just sitting on the bridge
as if we're in earth regular gravity but
we're moving forward is just crazy
it's just lazy it's just nothing to do
with what future physics is going to let
us do
they do it we all know why they do it
it's both
sort of easier for the budget for the
show but also it's familiar
right it's easy because we're actually
sitting
on chairs on the ground to imagine that
in spaceships the same thing will be
happening
right not because it's true and not
because we have any prospect
for technology in those directions just
because it's familiar
and you know if you have enough
unfamiliar things like tribbles and
vulcans why make things even weirder
that's the basic idea it's not because
there's any hope
for such technologies to really exist i
mean there's other things you can do to
sort of fake it
you could put magnets on yourself or
something like that but it's not
inertia negation there is no such thing
eric king says i am struck by the
influence one's native language has
on how they view and understand the
world around them my question to you is
how much do you think the language we
use to describe science might affect our
ability to really understand it
do you ever feel that language we use to
describe for instance quantum mechanics
is holding us back from truly
understanding it
i want to say yes and no you know if you
listen to the
podcast i just released with dean
buenomano
we talked about my half-baked idea
that the human thinking human cognition
has undergone undergone some sort of
phase transition where
we can manipulate symbols and reason
symbolically and algorithmically so we
become kind of touring machine capable
and at that point even though your
natural language does hold you back
it is a handicap that we can overcome
right we can think our way out of that
i mean sure i think that not not only
language
but just our intuition of the world is
an enormous barrier
to understanding quantum mechanics and
other parts of theoretical physics at a
deep level
we're just not trained to think that way
or to reason that way or to
conceptualize that way and language is
absolutely a part of it
but i don't think it holds us back in
any fundamental way i think it just
makes it harder
for us to do right it's not like a speed
of light barrier
is just like a hill we gotta climb and i
think that you know some of us are
trying to climb it
jessica wollen says i just read city by
clifford symac have you read it
it was written in the late 1940s and he
describes what sounds like multiverses
was that a concept
was that concept a thing in physics by
then
um so i haven't read it but i thought
it'd be fun to answer the question
because i want to say
i don't know whether that was a thing in
physics by then the idea of the
multiverse
um physicists are very bad in general at
understanding their own history and the
history of the ideas they talk about
uh my paying attention to physics didn't
really start
until i was a kid in the 1970s and then
a student of the 1980s
and the idea of the multiverse in the
1980s was just becoming popular
in physics and it was a combination of
things it was
inflationary cosmology gave us a
mechanism for potentially creating a
multiverse
the anthropic principle trying to
understand the cosmological constant
gave us a motivation for wanting there
to be a multiverse
and the landscape in string theory
was the idea that there could be
different laws of physics in different
parts of the multiverse so that sort of
gave us a mechanism for
solving the cosmological constant
problem coupled with inflation etc so
this whole
stew of ideas uh really made people
think
much more carefully about the multiverse
in the in the 1980s and 90s
but you notice that all of these are
driven by
other ideas so it's not i've said this
before i'll keep saying it again
it was not that physicists in the 80s or
90s said wow like the multiverse
wouldn't that be cool
like no one ever said that you were
forced into thinking about it by other
ideas and then you try to take it
seriously
so of course everett and the many
world's interpretation came in 1950s but
he didn't even call it the money world's
interpretation that wasn't
a label that got put on the theory until
1970
by bryce dewitt so i have no idea what
people are thinking about in the 1940s i
really don't and i say this because i
would like to like it'd be very
interesting
uh for someone to do a careful
historical analysis
of the concept of the idea of the
multiverse or maybe someone has and i
just don't know about it
you know sometimes i point to this paper
written by boltzmann ludwig boltzmann
back in 1895
boltzmann was trying to answer the
question why was the entropy the early
universe low just like we were talking
about just like i'm still trying to
answer that question right but
over 100 years ago and he was a smart
guy
uh you know he just to put in context
boltzmann and his friends
came up with statistical mechanics and
their definition of entropy and other
things
and their formulation of the second law
back in the 1870s
and in the 1890s for some reasons which
are a little bit obscure to me sort of
controversy flared up about it again and
uh boltzmann was responding to
criticisms by zermelo
cermelo later became famous as a pure
mathematician
set theory axioms right but he was
criticizing
boltzmann and boltzmann sort of offered
these different reasons why entropy
might have been low in the early
universe the problem that we now know as
the past hypothesis
and boltzmann invented what we might
call the multiverse and what we might
call the anthropic principle
he said well if the universe was
infinitely big he didn't know about
general relativity the big bang or
anything like that so a static
eternal infinitely big universe filled
with gas and dust and particles just
running around bumping into each other
most of the time in most of the places
it would be in thermal equilibrium
but occasionally there would be
fluctuations and the fluctuations would
as boltzmann says
sometimes because you have infinitely
long to wait
sometimes the fluctuation would be so
big as to create our universe
or at least our galaxy he didn't know
there were other galaxies right there's
a lot of things he didn't know in 1895
and so boltzmann says look in most of
this huge collection
we're in thermal equilibrium and
therefore dead you can't have life
in thermal equilibrium but in these
little pockets
where you randomly fluctuate into low
entropy states that's where
you can have life and maybe that's us
maybe that's what we do and this would
happen many times in many places
so it's both the multiverse and the
anthropic principle because he's saying
we're not going to find ourselves in the
dead places that are in thermal
equilibrium
now number one i don't know whether even
that analysis is correct
because he was kind of ignoring gravity
so i
don't know that things would actually
just keep bumping into each other over
and over again i suspect
that what would happen in that scenario
is gravitational instability and
lumpy regions would just absorb all the
matter and it would sit there
and empty out in between on
progressively larger scales as time went
on
forever so it would not remain uniformly
distributed
gravity is a tricky thing when it comes
to entropy but the other thing was of
course
his scenario is entirely 100 percent
a target of the boltzmann brain problem
and this was pointed out
years later by eddington arthur
eddington in the 1930s
who pointed out look look if that's if
that were the world
randomly fluctuating then we would
expect to live in the
smallest possible fluctuation and what
eddington said was it would just be one
mathematical physicist that's all you
would need because he was a mathematical
physicist
um so i don't know you know i don't know
where whether
he whether anyone back then used the
word multiverse or anything like that i
don't know whether these speculations by
eddington and others
had any uh impact on clifford cymac i
just don't know i mean certainly
science fiction over the course of the
20th century had a lot of fun with
alternate timelines and altered
histories and things like that
but i don't know the origin of it andrew
vernon smith says are there scientific
studies ongoing concerning where
quantum physics and neurobiology or
psychology merge
where choices consciously made in a
human brain and observations
deliberately collected by scientific
instruments each
collapse the wave function respectively
at the choice
made and state observed um i am not sure
what exactly you have in mind by the
last part of the
sentence you know it to my mind wave
functions collapse
when quantum systems decohere when they
become entangled with their environment
it could be so the question is how does
that happen
typically you know we talked about the
neutron going through the magnetic field
but you still need the neutron to
interact with something
and typically decoherence happens when
you
take that quantum superposition and you
amplify it
to something macroscopic right so people
in quantum mechanics talk about pointer
states
of macroscopic systems when you
literally have a little dial with a
pointer on it saying oh the neutron went
up or the neutron went down
and then photons will interact with that
pointer differently
photons in the environment and that
causes decoherence
so a human choice you know as i've said
in something deeply hidden and elsewhere
there's nothing about choices that
collapse the wave function
except when a choice depends on
some quantum event in your brain so you
know some
chemical reaction happened or didn't
happen because of quantum mechanics
and therefore in one branch of the wave
function you had pizza and the other had
you had chinese food right
so that would count as decoherence but
you don't know
you don't know when you make a decision
whether or not it depended on some
quantum event in your brain
and typically it doesn't typically it's
entirely classical so
there's no usual strong connection
between making decisions
and branching the wave function there is
a question you can ask about
is there any way in which the brain is
explicitly depending on the rules of
quantum mechanics that is to say
not just obeying the rules of classical
mechanics very famously roger penrose
and others have thought about
ways that could be true there's not a
lot of support for those ideas in the
physics community but you never know
there are
experiments going on maybe they'll find
it someday there is an idea due to
matthew fisher who is a condensed matter
physicist
at uc santa barbara at the kitp the
koble institute of theoretical physics
in santa barbara
his idea which actually i'm very very
fond of because i totally had this idea
myself
but i didn't know enough about either
quantum mechanics or condensed
metaphysics to make it real and matthew
did so he made it real
the idea is that you can have
elements atoms in your brain
that are part of neurons whose energy
can depend on whether the nuclei of the
atoms are entangled
in different ways for some reason it's
phosphorus i think that
matthew fisher pointed at as something
that maybe could be
relevant so you need to shield it from a
million other different forces and
that's exactly
why i didn't have myself the knowledge
to do this well
but um he he's he suggests he
hypothesizes
that there are conditions where neurons
in the brain could have their energies
dependent on
quantum entanglement now that has
nothing to do
with branching the wave function or
consciousness or anything like that
but it is possible just as it's possible
that entanglement is useful in
photosynthesis
it's possible that quantum effects are
important in the brain i think that's
something we're still studying right now
adam c says i currently find the terms
populism or populist
anti-democratic and elitist the google
definition is a politician who strives
to appeal to ordinary people who feel
their concerns are disregarded by
established elite groups
to me this sounds like a definition of
democracy shouldn't all political
candidates in a democracy strive for
this
ideal well yeah i mean words like
populism and populist are contentious
different people will
apply them in different ways and i think
that you know the google definition you
have there is fine
um but but the important part of it
is not just doing what the people want
it's specifically
this contrast being set up between
ordinary people and elite groups
right that's really where most uh that's
usually what is is being implied by
the label populist and that sounds
fair enough right ordinary people elite
groups which side are you going to be on
but if you go back into the very early
days of the podcast i interviewed yasha
monk
about liberal democracy and populism and
things like that and the case he makes
which i think is
uh at least plausible is that in
practice
uh all the effort is going into defining
what you mean by the ordinary people
right um you know if you think about the
actual
populists that have been either
self-identified or externally identified
as populists
um they very very often
get their oomph by defining the ordinary
people in contrast
not with the elites but with some other
outsiders right
here's the in-group here's the outside
group it could be foreigners it could be
minority groups within
the society or whatever so in practice
the theory goes populism is really about
dividing people
rather than uniting people and of course
i do actually think
that there's a real problem in modern
democracy
with responsiveness to people
on the part of the elites i'm not quite
sure how to
deal with that but there's but i also
think there's an absolutely very very
real danger
in demonizing the other whether it's
foreigners or minority members or
whatever and that's the danger in my
mind
to populism very very often
it's a step towards right out
authoritarianism
right you claim to be the voice of the
people
you repress other voices and then you
abrogate power to yourself
that's that's something that happens
over and over again there's no doubt
it's something we have to watch out for
anders hector says in the big picture
and in the interview with neda
engelhardt
you describe conservation of information
as the state of the system
and what we know about it but that is
sort of a state of affairs of the system
it's aboutness of the state how about
the state
as such would you say the information
only exists in relation to thinking
beings or does it have an existence
independent of any biology
so you know as usual i can't exactly
remember what i say it every time so
the information when we talk about
conserving from conservation of
information
we are not talking about what we know
about it
in any sense whatsoever information is
conserved
whether or not we know about it the
information in the sense of conservation
of information is
you can think of it if you want as a
counterfactual idea
all of the information you would need to
know
to follow the dynamics of the system to
predict the dynamics of the system under
the laws of physics
so it's really complete information that
you would need
complete information that is there in
the system whether you have it
or not okay so laplace's demon
has access to all the information but
you don't that's okay the information is
still there
that's the information that is conserved
so it has nothing to do
with living beings biology anything like
that
in that sense of course the word
information like many other words
is used in different senses by different
people at different times but that's
what it means in that context
chris fautash says in the first
mindscape episode i listened to a couple
of years ago you spoke about how the
largest possible number
allowed by some physics law i think you
referred to hilbert's base
and it was something like 10 to the
power of a few hundreds if my memory is
right the question would be is there a
hard
physical value to infinity so to refresh
your memory
it's not the maximum number it's not the
biggest number that we're talking about
here
what we're talking about is the size of
hilbert
space so hilbert's space is david
hilbert is the mathematician who it's
named after
hilbert space is a particular kind of
vector space where you can take dot
products
but instead of being two-dimensional or
three-dimensional it's a vector space
that is
some number of dimensions there's
different numbers of hilbert spaces you
can have a two-dimensional
hilbert space three-dimensional
four-dimensional et
um quantum mechanics says that the state
of the universe is a vector in hilbert
space
i referred to my paper earlier called
reality as a vector in hilbert space
and the question is how many dimensions
does hilbert space have does
the hilbert space describing the
universe have and we think
i think some people think that our
observable universe can be described as
a vector
or a matrix in a finite dimensional
hilbert space but a big dimension
the dimensionality we throw around is
something like 10 to the power
10 to the power 120 that's the number
that you're
thinking of probably um but that's not
a physical limit to infinity
so it's the number of different possible
things that can happen in the world
very very roughly speaking number of
different states the universe can be in
number of different
um distinguishable states the universe
can be in
in some sense but i can write down
numbers much bigger than that if you
know i can write down the number 10 to
the power 10 to the 10 to the 10 to the
10.
way bigger than the dimensionality of
hilbert's face
um i could never write down all zeros in
that number there's not enough atoms in
the universe to do it
but i can imagine those numbers so all
of which is to say
there is a very interesting question
about the foundations of mathematics
whether or not you need infinity there's
a movement
i think in the early 20th century of
finitism maybe it was the
late 19th century um to really see
whether or not we could just get rid of
like all of the difficulties in the
philosophy of math and the foundations
of set theory and all these things
deal with infinities in some way
infinity is really where you get into
trouble
and it's easy to imagine infinity right
you say well i have one and two and
three and four and five and i keep going
i never stop
so there's an infinite number of whole
numbers
um but maybe you don't need to and maybe
maybe maybe maybe there is a
relationship between that idea and
physics
um there's no necessary relationship but
maybe the physical world
doesn't require an infinite number of
numbers or a well
established notion of infinity to make
sense of it honestly i don't know that's
beyond my pay grade
even in hilbert's space there's even if
there's an infinite number of
sorry even if there are an infinite
number of distinguishable states
orthogonal states perpendicular states
there's still an infinite number of
vectors they're just almost aligned with
each other
most of them so still there's an
infinite number of states the universe
could be in
so i really don't know what to make of
that i'm not the person to ask sorry
about that
steven bernard says topics and questions
at the bleeding edge of physics invoke
hypotheses that are either in principle
or in any reasonable foreseeable
practice
unobservable my philosophical question
is what is your opinion of the
epistemological weight of such
hypotheses
and how much work can they be expected
to do are they to be taken as seriously
as experimentally falsifiable ones
well if you want a slightly more
detailed answer i did write a paper
called beyond falsifiability where i
talked a little bit about this issue
um you know i'm not especially an expert
or interested in
the philosophy of the practice of
science so i think these are interesting
important questions but it's not my kind
of
specialty my kind of expertise so i
can't i can't really offer you a
definitive answer here
but i think that what you can observe
is overrated when it comes to judging
scientific theories
because you can have unobservable things
whose existence or absence
affects how we think about observable
things right
so quarks are individually unobservable
but they affect how we think about
observable things virtual particles are
even more unobservable
but they play a role in explaining
observable phenomena
so something like the multiverse the
cosmological multiverse where you have
regions of space
very very far away where conditions are
very very different
does that does the existence or
non-existence
of those other parts of the universe
play a role
in how we think about the observable
universe well
if something like the cosmological
constant the vacuum energy of empty
space
is not determined by some as yet unknown
but perfectly deterministic laws of
physics and is instead
just different from place to place in
the multiverse
then our job as scientists is very
different depending on those two
options right what kind of ways you
think about the cosmos
constants does depend on that issue
therefore you need to take it
epistemologically seriously right even
if you can't see them
outside or not in the case of the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics
the formalism says there are other
worlds other branches of the wave
function where different experimental
results happened
we'll never see them but they play a
role in the formalism that we have to
explain what we do see
so i think that's a much better
criterion to use than what you can
directly see
falsify etc remember you don't falsify
predictions there are plenty of
predictions that are completely
unfalsifiable but yet you believe them
um you falsify theories once you can
falsify a theory then
it's a good thing to think about it
scientifically but that theory might
have
specific predictions that are
unfalsifiable i shouldn't bother you at
all
andrew vickerstaff says what future
discovery or observation would increase
or decrease the credence of many worlds
compared to other foundational theories
of quantum mechanics
right so speaking of which you know look
many worlds says
there is a wave function or a state
vector it evolves
all the time under the schrodinger
equation
so all you need to do to falsify the
mini world's interpretation is to do an
experiment
where the wave function does not obey
the schrodinger equation
these experiments are ongoing roger
penrose makes predictions
that we should see them right there's
other theories of objective collapses
that says we should see them
so that's just one way also you could
find evidence for
dynamical variables other than the wave
function because those don't exist in
many worlds so it's plenty of ways in
which you could
experimentally do these things they're
hard experiments to do and they may
never
converge on anything but you know
they're there in principle if you care
about the philosophy of it rather than
the practice of it
uh there's zero question that many
worlds is completely 100 percent super
duper falsifiable
victor yatkin says can you envision a
set of conditions for a simplified
laplace's demon experiment where many
variables are controlled but with
sufficient computing power and knowledge
of initial conditions
so we can accurately predict the actions
of a human for a short period of time
uh no i cannot humans are very very
complicated
you know and not only uh
of order 100 billion neurons in our head
but have order
what uh hundreds of trillions of
connections between those neurons and
neurons are not individually simple
neurons are kind of complicated
so no even measuring where all the
different pieces are
would be impossible much less actually
calculating what all those pieces would
then do
so no worries about that in my mind
carlos nunez says what do you think
about the following moral realist
argument
morality concerns the well-being of
conscious creatures and if we want to
maximize their well-being we have to
take into account the biological
constraints of said creatures
that is to say that there are some moral
facts about us humans and primates in
general which result from our
evolutionary history
uh so sorry carlos but i don't think
that's a very good argument at all
it is full of wild non-sequiturs sorry
about that
so morality concerns the well-being of
conscious creatures
sure that's just a definition right i
mean that's just what you mean by the
word morality like if there weren't any
conscious creatures
there wouldn't be any morality that's
fine but then you say
and if we want to maximize their
well-being well wait hold on
who says that we want to maximize their
well-being
that's not implicit in the definition of
well-being or morality or anything else
that is
one particular possible moral axiom that
you might want to defend
other people don't think that our job
should be to maximize the well-being of
conscious creatures maybe
maximizing the overall well-being is
something that would hurt some people
really badly
while it helps other people and so they
don't want to do that i think personally
just the idea that there is something to
maximize
that there is something called the
aggregate well-being that we can
measure and quantify is wildly wrong
personally
um so that's just a leap that is is
completely impermissible and then you
say we have to take into account the
biological constraints of said creatures
sure uh no one ever has argued
that science has no impact on how we go
about being moral
like that would be a crazy argument
there's an argument that says that
science doesn't determine morality that
morality is not
part of science but science describes
the real world if you want to be moral
in the real world you have to take
science into account
obviously and then you say that is to
say that there are some moral facts and
about humans which result from our
evolutionary history so no that is not
sorry that is not to say that the idea
that you have to take into account
biological constraints
does not lead clearly to there are moral
facts that result from our evolutionary
history that
that again that's there's just a huge
leap there
you know there are constraints but they
don't lead to moral facts they don't
tell you what is right and what's wrong
they tell you that
if you know what is right and what is
wrong from some other reasons then you
have to take into account biological
constraints in achieving them
right uh so it's just way more you know
let me back up a little bit
this is not hard this is not
controversial like no sensible person
thinks that you can derive moral facts
from pure logic
uh that you drive it from somewhere
maybe like i don't think you can derive
them from anywhere in any objective way
but you need extra input somewhere like
i had russ
schaefer landau was one of the world's
leading moral realists
on the podcast and he thinks that it's
our intuitions that give us
some insight into what the moral facts
are but you have to get them from
somewhere
they don't just appear from nowhere in
particular uh
well i'm not going to go into
particulars you've heard me talk about
this before i
read i wrote a book called the big
picture where i talk about this and i
wrote
many blog posts so those are my feelings
personally
michael edelman says several episodes
back you said half ingest
something like maybe game theory is just
physics
given all the mathematical patterns that
pop up across all matter
of systems and structures do you think
that tells us something interesting and
deep about the way the universe is
structured
um well i i don't i can't say that i
think that right now because i'm not
sure
or even especially confident that game
theory is just physics so what i meant
by that statement was you know game
theory is a way
of determining certain strategies for
certain formal
games under certain conditions right
like given certain payoff structures
what should individual
actors in the game do that's what game
theory tells you how to do
what i meant by saying maybe it's just
physics is that kind of optimization
problem uh is something that we're
familiar with from physics in other
contexts you know
it's all the time happening the
different physical systems optimize
something the principle of least action
says that individual particles minimize
their action when you have statistical
mechanics or thermodynamics
systems go to equilibrium where they
maximize their entropy things like that
right
so i'm just wondering out loud whether
or not there is some
more formal connection between these
physical systems that we know
optimize maximize minimize something and
the search for strategies in game theory
but i don't know that it's true
so i haven't done that yet i'm thinking
about it uh
i don't know i probably guess it's not
true in a useful way like maybe there's
some very formal
analogy there but i don't necessarily
see that there's going to be some useful
analogy those are a different thing
okay brad goldberg says you often stress
that in quantum field theory
fields represent a deeper more complete
concept than particles
however standard first quantize string
theory
looks more like a theory of fundamental
particles zipping around where
subsystems are not arranged into a
nearest neighbor structure
by analogy to quantum field theory and
relativistic quantum mechanics do you
think that the string
fields of string field theory are a
relatively deeper more comprehensive
formalism of the theory than first
quantize
strings so for those of you who are not
experts
um the idea here is the following we
know about quantum field theory
quantum field theory is the best current
empirically successful
way we have of understanding the world
around us experimentally in physics and
so forth
you need quantum field theory to have
particles created and destroyed
obey the rules of relativity all that
stuff so even though you might have
thought
back in the day i don't know in the
1920s that you could make a
theory of particles actually richard
feynman thought this in the 40s
so he but you know that's okay you make
hypotheses it didn't work out so feynman
was hoping that his little feynman
diagrams
would enable us to get rid of quantum
field theory um we could just talk about
particles right to sum up the effect of
an infinite number of particles that's
better than doing a field that's what he
thought
it doesn't really work that way the
truth is that the the particles and
finding diagrams are vibrations of
quantum fields
okay the fields are more fundamental now
in string theory
as brad says um the usual way that
string theory is formulated is
more like particles than fields
so you talk about individual vibrating
strings just like you would talk about
individual particles and you do find
diagrams with them and that is your
theory okay
um you might therefore by analogy say
well what you
really want is a string field
and maybe that would give you deeper
insights into the dynamics or nature of
string theory
and people have tried that ed whitton
has has made
important contributions here murray
gelman and barton svok wrote papers
about
string field theory but it's never
really caught on in the same way that
quantum field theory
replaced point particles in some way and
honestly
brad i do not know enough about it
to say why not um again people have
tried
and but it's just not really
operationally panned out to be
that useful or that insightful or
whatever is that because it's not
there is it because string theory really
is a theory of individual
strings rather than fields that are
collections of strings
or is it just we human beings haven't
been smart enough to think about it in
the right way
i really don't know i did do a little
bit of thinking about it i thought about
what you might call classical string
theory but i never wrote any paper or
anything like that
about it um it would certainly be
mathematically complicated
so i i you know one of the possible
options is
people like me have like tried it and
thought about it and going yeah that's
too complicated it's not enough i think
about anymore i have other things that i
can that i can think about so
i'm not a strength theorist
professionally so i'm not really the one
to ask but my impression is
working string theorists don't really
think that much about stringfield theory
and i'm not exactly sure
what reason they would give okay now i'm
going to combine
two questions here greg says special
relativity says that the speed of light
is invariant for all observers
in inertial reference frames but i'm
confused about whether this is an
assumption
an experimental result a law of nature
or a logical consequence of other things
we're sure of in physics
and brian carbody says i understand that
the speed that photons travel in a
vacuum arises from the magnetic and
electric constants
which are fundamental parameters of the
universe i also understand the geometric
argument from special relativity
that there must be a maximum speed at
which things can travel
my question is why is this maximum speed
for everything
also the exact speed to which
electromagnetic waves propagate and not
some other speed
why is the speed of neutrinos etc
seemingly limited by electromagnetic
constraints so both of these are about
you know what is the nature of
the speed of light in modern physics and
so to
greg's question it's actually kind of a
nice framing of it he says
i'm confused about whether this is an
assumption experimental result a law of
nature or a logical consequence of other
things and the answer is it's all those
so the thing i think that the the hidden
question that is being begged here is
is physics as we understand it or as we
will
understand it or should understand it
some kind of axiomatic system
where we start with the most
foundational statements and then build
everything on top of them
um or not and you know for
individual the answer is that for
individual physical theories you can
very
often write down a set of axioms and
derive the theory from it for general
relativity or special relativity or
quantum field theory or whatever but
you can also very often write down an
entirely different looking
set of axioms and derive the same theory
from it
and if when that is possible to do
arguing over which are the right
axioms or the right sort of foundational
pieces for whatever you're trying to do
is not always a useful use of your time
productive use of your time in other
words
i think that the right way to think
about theories
in physics is not as there's a
foundational set of axioms and we derive
everything from them
it's a little bit more holistic than
that right
uh there's a set of statements that are
true and they're all true
and it's not like some that are truer
than others once you have a
well-defined physical theory and you can
choose different ways that some of them
can be derived from others etc but the
whole thing fits together
it's more like a web than a hierarchy
where you start with the bottom level
and build everything on top of that
bottom level
so the fact that the speed of light is
invariant for all inertia
for all inertial observers by the way
it's not inertial observers it's just
invariant no matter what you don't need
to be in an inertial reference frame
the laws of physics are invariant for
all inertial observers
is maybe what you have in mind but the
speed of light is constant for everybody
so is that an assumption or a logical
consequence of other things
either way you can do it either way so
it's it's uh i think it's a slight
change of shift about how you think
about
the role of these sorts of statements is
it an experimental result also yes it
certainly is also
an experimental result and for brian's
question you know what about the other
things right like gravitons
and things like that why are they
limited by the speed of light i mean you
i think
you're sort of i can see in the way that
you phrase the question you're almost
there you're almost grasping it the
point is
um there is a speed limit right
that's the point of special relativity
there's a speed limit there are light
cones as we call them
the fact that light electromagnetic
waves or photons or however you want to
think about light
the fact that light happens to move at
the speed limit
is much much less important than the
fact that there is a speed limit
after all light doesn't move at the
speed limit if it's like moving through
water or air or something like that
it's only moves at the speed limit in
vacuum so
what you have is a system where there is
a speed limit a maximum speed a limiting
velocity
and then you say well what kinds of
things move
at that velocity and which kinds of
things move slower
and the answer is from a particle point
of view
massless particles move at that speed
massive particles move slower than that
so really all you're asking is why are
photons massless just like gravitons are
massless
and the answer is because of symmetries
in the deep down laws of physics that
give them their mass or
actually symmetries to prevent them from
getting mass it's a better way of
saying it and i can't give you an
airtight argument for why massless
particles move at the speed of light but
there is an
intuitive argument for sort of why it
makes sense
if you have a massive particle
you can always consider that particle in
its rest frame
right a particle moves slower than the
speed of light you can always
change your own speed so you are at rest
with respect to that particle
and then you can ask how much energy
does it have and the answer is
equals mc squared that's the energy in a
particle in its rest frame if it's
moving faster
it's moving at a non-zero velocity then
it has more energy that's kinetic energy
as well as
rest energy right but a particle that is
at rest
has a minimum energy that's its rest
energy that's what the formula equals mc
squared tells you
and then the way to think about
what mass is from this point of view is
how much energy does a particle have
when it's at rest
okay um so every particle that has a
non-zero mass has to be able to be at
rest
to define that and therefore the other
way around
every particle that can be at rest has a
mass
and vice versa and so the particles that
can be at rest or the particles that
have mass
if you always move at the speed of light
then you can never be at rest
by the definition by that's those are
the rules of special relativity
particles that
things move the speed of light always
move at the speed of light so things
that move at the speed of light don't
have a rest mass
therefore they are massless that's what
we say they still have energy but all
their energy comes from their motion
rather than from their rest mass so
hopefully that gives a little bit of
intuition there
alexander freund says in discussing
entanglement i've heard you refer to
a degree or extent of entanglement for
example that two particles are very
entangled or slightly entangled
what exactly does this refer to my basic
intuition is the two particles are
either entangled or they are not
uh nope that's a bad intuition to have
so think about you know two particles
that might be entangled let's say two
particles that have a spin
right so spin up spin down there's two
particles there's alice's particle and
bob's particle
and if you think about how they're
entangled usually you're given an
example something like uh you're in a
superposition
of both particles are spin up plus both
particles are spin down
right that's an entangled superposition
such that if you measure
the spin of one and it's up you
instantly know the other spin is
up also sometimes by the way it's
they're opposite but it doesn't matter
it can be oppositely entangled or
entangled the same way so long as
they're entangled
but that is a particular superposition
right there's another state
that the particles can be in where
they're both just spin up
right if both particles are just 100
spin up that is not entangled even
though they're related to each other
you don't learn anything about one
particle by measuring the other one
because you already knew
that the both particles were spin up so
if you measure one and see it spin up
you don't learn anything about the other
one
okay so that other superposition
up up plus down down that's maximally
entangled
because secretly what we're not telling
you but what is true is that
pythagoras theorem is at work here right
this
superposition has coefficients so it's a
times both particles up plus b times
both particles are down with the rule a
squared plus b squared equals one
because they have to their squares need
to sum to one that's pythagoras theorem
so it's really if it's an equal
superposition it's
1 over the square root of 2 up up
plus 1 over the square root of 2 down
down that gives you a unit vector
whereas if you just have up up and
nothing else then it's 1 times
up up and once you realize that once you
put back the numbers in that people
like me usually hide from you in popular
level discussions you realize
the numbers could be any two numbers
that whose squares add to one
so the first the up up could have a
coefficient
the square root of 0.99 and the down
down could have a coefficient the square
root of 0.01
okay that is a superposition but it's
almost the same as just having it all be
up up
so that is a slightly entangled
superposition if you went all the way so
it's only up up it's not entangled at
all
and it becomes more and more entangled
as the two terms
up up and down down go from being one
comma zero to being
one over square root of two one over
square root of two so you can have any
amount of entanglement
uh from zero to maximal
luis suarez says our life forms entropy
reducing systems
so i'm tempted to say have you ever met
a life form
most life forms i know are not entropy
reducing systems no in fact
every life form i know is not in entropy
reducing systems
it's the other way around life forms are
necessarily entropy
increasing systems if we include the
entropy of everything the entropy of the
universe as a whole
what life forms do is they take in
low entropy energy from the universe
whether it's sunlight for photosynthesis
or food for animals or something like
that and they
increase its entropy they extract energy
from it by
degrading that energy by converting that
energy into waste heat with higher
entropy
and that is how these organisms maintain
themselves repair themselves
metabolize and do all the things that
they do so life is just another way to
increase the entropy of the universe
from some point of view
james maddox says the planck length and
plonk time are supposed to represent a
scale where quantum gravity becomes
important
i've also heard that they may represent
the quanta of space and time and the
size of the smallest black hole
but aren't they just constructed by
combining constants of nature until the
units work out
how sure are we that these exact values
have physical significance
i think it's a really good question
because the answer is we're a little bit
less sure than you might think
from what people say so on the one hand
you're completely correct
that these units plonk length etc are
just constructed from other
laws of physics right um
it's numerology in some sense but on the
other hand
uh physicists are trained to sort of
have expectations about when different
effects
become important when you travel near
the speed of light
you expect special relativity to become
important when
the gravitational force the
gravitational
constant is uh similar in magnitude to
other things going on in your system you
might expect gravity to become
important when the action of your system
is close to
h-bar planck's constant you might expect
quantum mechanics become important etc
and so on so
the fact that when people say quantum
gravity
becomes important at the playing scale
that is the expectation
of physicists it's just a rough back of
the envelope kind of expectation
in fact in string theory uh there is
something called the string scale
which is not the same as the playing
scale but it's close it is a
dimensionless number
times the planck scale and so in string
theory stringy effects become important
a little bit earlier than
the planck scale that you might hit so
the point is we don't think we know the
once and for all theory of quantum
gravity
but when we do we expect that
intrinsically quantum gravitational
effects will become important at around
the planck scale
the specific theory might tell us that
the actual time
or regime or parameters for which they
become important is a little bit
different
if it were very different that would
require some extra physical mechanism
right and indeed large extra dimensions
of space-time would provide such a
mechanism gravity can become much
important
important way before what we know as the
playing scale so we don't know if there
are we haven't found any large extra
dimensions so that's still the plank
skill is still our
best bet ludwig schubert says
wikipedia tells me that we are in the
middle of the stelliferous
era a time period in the existence of
the universe during which new stars are
still being formed
does this mean the sun burning out
shouldn't worry us too much because we
can expect new stars to form for another
one to 100 trillion years
that would sound like really good news
to me suggesting most of the useful
lifespan of the universe is still ahead
of us
well ludwig i don't know why you're
worried
even if it were just the sun it would
still be a few billion more years
so i'm not quite sure what exactly your
anxiety
is coming from certainly you and i will
not be around to worry about these
things and now you might i get it i mean
you might want
life to exist for as long as possible
but you know let's be a little bit
realistic here we don't know what form
life is going to be in or take or adopt
even a million years from now much less
a billion or a trillion years
from now so i mean to actually answer
your question
yes stars are still forming in some
galaxies star formation is more or less
over
roughly speaking elliptical galaxies are
done
forming stars that's not 100 true
because stars explode and
and put out gas and dust into the regime
into the space around them and then more
stars can form from that
but uh spiral galaxies are the ones that
still have ambient
interstellar gas and dust and you can
still form more stars whereas
ellipticals have sort of used up all
their gas and dust
but there's a cycle like you say stars
explode
they expel gas and dust into the
interstellar medium and you can form
more stars
so yes there will be a long time we
believe
in front of us in the future where more
stars are still
formed now there are details like even
if you want to say
forget about technology and
civilizations and stuff like that
will the next generation of stars be
appropriate
for forming life around them so will the
next generation of stars have the same
kind of solar systems and planets that
current stars have
i don't know i mean probably but
honestly i don't know so
i think that it's it's certainly
plausible to me that
stars like the sun solar systems like
ours will form
on into the future for a long time but i
actually don't know like maybe they're
all much lower mass stars maybe they
burn a long time but
don't burn very brightly i i just don't
know my point is only that there are a
lot of details that go into these kinds
of questions they're not easy ones to
answer
peter bamber says from the outside the
united states looks like a strange
country
with insane attitudes to guns in many
states and many other
unique things baseball is american
exceptionalism
as clear from within as it is from
without and how do you feel about it
so i think the phrase american
exceptionalism isn't the right one to
use here you mean something like
american
american particularity or something like
that strangeness uniqueness
exceptionalism uh is a phrase
used by pro-american people to say that
america is better
than everywhere else and that's that's
one issue a different issue is is
america forgetting about better or worse
is just different from everywhere else
you know and these are always hard
questions to answer
because i think that almost every
question every every country
is unique in its own ways right
the united states did have a unique
position
in the world for the last roughly
century okay
not maybe not entirely a century of
being the most powerful technologically
advanced and richest country
okay um a century is not that long
historically speaking and there's zero
guarantee
that that kind of condition extends into
the future as we all know so china is an
obvious
example of a country that very well
could overtake the united states
in technology wealth all those things um
but being in that position does you know
allow a country
to start patting itself on the back and
treating itself as
special um i'm sure the countries
throughout history have done that i'm
sure the roman empire did that back in
the roman empire ruling the world days
i'm sure china did that in its empire
days etc
so you know i don't know i'm not that
i'm not that surprised or struck by it
the other thing is that that is is worth
mentioning is that america is
big as a country um
you know we are we literally have two
borders one with mexico
one with canada and many many people in
the united states don't live any near
anywhere near
one of those borders and the canadian
border which is much longer is with one
with a country that also speaks english
and came from sort of the same
uh predecessors colonial past as we did
so unlike people in many other countries
we're not
constantly visiting other countries
constantly being exposed
to uh cultures from other countries
constantly
sharing resources and things like that
you know there's no european union
in north america that that kind of thing
um
so it's a different kind of expectation
like you know there's
plenty of americans who have never left
america or don't really want to
whereas there's not that many french or
german people uh at least
the fraction is smaller let's put it
that way so if you live in europe
then you know experiencing other
countries and getting to know them
is just much more part of your everyday
expectation than if you live in america
and you know none of this is right or
wrong every country has its good parts
its bad parts etc
it's just hard to judge other countries
or your own country objectively
so i don't like to go too far in these
comparisons
sandro stuckey says my friend max and i
thoroughly enjoyed your discussion with
justin clark doan as it sparked an
interesting discussion among us and our
colleagues
during the discussion max raised the
following point if we can be pluralists
about mathematical and moral theories
and truths
can we be pluralists about realism
itself or is there some objectively
unique and true meaning of the word
real so i can only give you my opinion
here
we don't know these are the kinds of
questions where you know it could be
very very wrong
at the deepest level but i don't think
it's analogous
actually um i am a reality realist
i think that whatever there is whatever
the real world is
um there is something that it is right
there's something that is uniquely the
real world
now we might eventually find out that
there are different ways of talking
about the real world i mean there
clearly are different ways of talking
about the real world at different levels
of approximation
right there are emerging higher level
descriptions there might even be
different ways of talking about the real
world at the single fundamental level
you know as a as some kind of analogy
in classical mechanics those of you who
are either physics educated or
taken by big pictures in the universe
videos um
you can think about just classical
mechanics in a newtonian
language where there are particles and
they're being pushed around by forces
or you can think about it in a
hamiltonian language
where momentum is just as real and
fundamental as position is
it's not just derived it's a separate
independent quantity
or you can think about it from a
lagrangian point of view
where you have the action which is
defined over the whole trajectory of the
particle
and that is what gives you the motion of
the particle so
ontologically these sound like very
different choices for what is real and
what is fundamental
but they describe exactly the same
physical theory so
i'm very open to that i'm very open to
the possibility
that reality can be described at the
most fundamental level
in very different ways but i don't even
know what it would mean
to say that reality is different
then what then you know i think we all
live in the same reality i think there
is a unique world in which we live i
think we discover things about it
in a very contingent slow approximate
fallible way
but i think that there is a reality
there i know that not everyone agrees
with that but i'm honestly not even
clear what it could mean for that not to
be
true we seem to share the same world uh
in
a very real way so that's where i'm
voting
until there's good evidence otherwise
daniela cortezzi says could it be
that libertarian free will appears to be
incompatible with the laws of physics
because it cannot be captured by
mathematics
i mean suppose that it is real how would
we express it in the equations of
physics so i think
there's something that you're getting
your finger on that that i'm very
sympathetic with here
uh so the lack of libertarian free will
can be re-expressed as saying that human
beings
just obey the laws of physics okay we
have no way of being a law unto
ourselves
just being a person and an agent does
not give us in any sense
the ability to override what the
rules of the core theory tell us that
our atoms and particles should be doing
that's non-libertarian free will so
what is the alternative i mean we call
it libertarian free will but what does
it mean really
like what would it be um
does it mean there are other equations
that govern the choices people make but
they're not the laws of physics
does it mean that there are no equations
at all and what would that mean like
even if
even if human behavior was unpredictable
presumably
you could still come up with a
probability measure and say well
there's a probability that certain
things happen and the probability they
don't
certain actions are taken by certain
agents and conscious creatures
after all that's just what we do in
quantum mechanics right we still call it
a law of physics
so i'm a little concerned that there
isn't any good definition of what you
would
mean by libertarian free will but it
doesn't bother me that much because i
don't believe in libertarian free will
so
i'm kind of not worried about this it
reminds me of
when we had back in 2012 when i
organized the moving naturalism forward
workshop and so the idea was get a bunch
of naturalists in the same room
and rather than debating with theists or
religious people
try to work on the questions that we had
amongst ourselves
which are multiple and people got stuck
right at the beginning trying to define
what naturalism
is and i was like you know don't don't
spend our time doing that because
it is hard to define but it's only hard
to define because you don't know what
supernaturalism is
like naturalism makes perfect sense
there are laws of physics and there's
there's stuff and it obeys the laws of
physics that's naturalism right
supernaturalism is hard to define but
who cares we're naturalists we don't
need to worry about that i feel the same
way about libertarian free will
okay we have i think yeah we have a
whole bunch of questions that i'm
grouping together so let me just read
all these questions and then riff on
what the answers are
deepti amara surya says
how do conservation laws fit into the
many worlds interpretation
rob griber says hal or graber sorry
how does an everett many worlds
interpretation reconcile with the
conservation of matter and energy do
matter and energy multiplied to fill
each new world
douglas law says why is the creation of
a new world
not a violation of information traveling
faster than light
joseph tongreti says it would seem
according to the many worlds
interpretation that our world is not
just the splitter from which other
worlds emerge
but also a continuous split e can our
world simultaneously split from more
than one trunk world
and can we deduce that there was an
original trunk version of the universe
from which all the other worlds split
suraj rajan says couldn't you clarify
the many world's explanation for the
double slit
experiment i got a bit confused after
you mentioned the last ama
about both being in the same branch of
the wave function
and jeff b finally says the branching of
the wave function makes sense to me when
talking about a simple
two-state system like spin but there is
a conceptual challenge extending this to
position measurements
in order to make things make sense like
the double slit experiment
we need to think of the wave function as
a superposition of each possible
position of the particle
but is there a philosophical explanation
for why the wave function
chooses to decompose itself in this way
so specifically as a superposition of
position
rather than different kinds of things
okay so these are not all the same
questions certainly but they're all in
the
world if you will of uh many worlds and
branching and what defines
branches and how does that remain
compatible with things we know like
conservation laws so let me let me just
discuss a little bit what is meant
by the branching and then we can go into
the conservation laws so remember as we
just discussed a little bit ago
in many worlds the fundamental way we
describe the world is as a vector
it's a vector in some super duper high
dimensional vector space called hilbert
space
okay and what is really happening when
you branch the wave function
is that you can always write a vector as
the sum of two other vectors right if i
ever write
just draw an arrow in some direction
i can always decompose that arrow into
the sum of two arrows 45 degrees away
from it
right 45 degrees on either side and each
of the shorter arrows has one over the
square root of two the length of the
longer one and i can add them together
to get the longer one
and in a much higher dimensional vector
space i can do that over and over and
over again
so i can write any vector as the sum of
a huge number of other vectors each one
of which is very tiny
right so i can make a big vector by
adding up little vectors
to get the big one so that's all just
math that's all just formalism there's
no physical
content there in many worlds the
specific thing that is happening
is that some vectors are preferred over
others and the reason why is because we
make this
division of the physical stuff of the
world into the systems we care about
and the environment the environment is
everything we don't care about okay
and then the environment is constantly
monitoring the system the photons or the
box of gas the gas in the box that we're
dealing with
are constantly bumping into the system
and in some sense becoming entangled
with it
if the system is in a superposition if
it's a macroscopic system
in a superposition it entangles with the
environment very quickly that's
decoherence that's what we talked about
okay
so what we call branches of the wave
functions a long lead up to saying what
we call branches of the wave function
are those little vectors
that we add together to make the big
vector which is the wave function of the
universe
where the little vectors are ones that
don't become entangled anymore
with the environment so the classic
example here is schrodinger's cat right
if you have schrodinger's cat you have a
cat that is in a super position
of awaken asleep i like to put it but
what really matters
is not whether the cat is awake and
asleep or alive and dead what matters is
the cat is in a superposition of two
different macroscopic configurations
of the cat it could be schrodinger's
rock or
schrodinger's hat or whatever as long as
you put it
macroscopically in a superposition of
two different positions
because then what happens is those two
parts of the superposition
interact differently with photons some
photons will hit
the cat if it's in one place but not in
the other place
that's what causes decoherence wave
function branches you get two branches
but then
crucially super duper crucially once
that happens once you have just
one branch once you once you're
considering what happens just on one
branch
you have a cat it's in some location
photons are still hitting it
right but they're not entangling with it
because on that branch the cat is in
one's particular configuration one
particular position
that's what's called a pointer state and
the photons just keep hitting it and
bouncing off or being absorbed or
whatever
but they're not entangling it they're
not interacting with it differently
depending on different
parts of the quantum wave function of
the cat okay so that's why
certain vectors certain quantum states
are preferred because they remain
robust under being monitored by the
environment
okay i hope that is all useful
information now let's try to use it to
answer some of these questions
so as far as conservation laws matter
energy etc i did just write a paper on
this and a blog post explaining the
paper so
i encourage you to dig up on my blog i
have not been blogging very much so it's
not hard to find go to the blog
preposterousuniverse.com blog and you'll
find a blog post explaining
how energy conservation works in many
worlds and the answer is it works pretty
well but not exactly
and this is sort of an interesting
subtle thing because
when it comes because this speaks to the
other question about conservation laws
something like electric charge turns out
to be different
than energy in many worlds and the
reason why is because
electric charge is something that the
universe can be an
exact state of so in fact it probably is
in a state of zero electric charge if
you were going to guess right that would
be the easiest guess zero total electric
charge
plenty of positive charges plenty of
negative charges but they come in equal
amounts okay
and that's fine nothing wrong with that
things go on
but with energy energy is what
tells us how the universe evolves with
time
and the specific way quantum mechanics
works the specific way the hamiltonian
the
sorry the specific way the schrodinger
equation works in quantum mechanics
is that if you put a quantum system in a
state of exact energy
so you know precisely what the energy is
and it's not a combination of different
energies it's one's precise value
then the system doesn't evolve at all
nothing happens
all of the time evolution in quantum
mechanics
happens because real physical systems
are superpositions of systems with
slightly different energies
and those slightly different energy
subsystems evolve at slightly different
frequencies that beat against each other
to constructively interfere
destructively interfere etc and
all motion and all time evolution in the
world is that
in quantum mechanics so unlike electric
charge
energy is something where we can't be in
an exact
value of the energy we have to be in a
superposition and what that means as i
explained in the
in the blog post which is based on a
paper i wrote with jackie laudman
what that means is that the particular
set of
energies that go into our universe can
change with time they don't change from
one set of energies to a completely
different set but you can narrow down
right so you can have a universe that is
a
superposition of many different energy
states but then
as decoherence happens as the universe
evolves you can sort of
sample from fewer and fewer different
values of the energy so that the average
energy for your branch of the wave
function
changes over time so that's an
interesting feature
of of quantum mechanics now
it's explicable and perfectly sensible
within many worlds
it also happens in the copenhagen
interpretation but it makes much less
sense like many other things in the
copenhagen interpretation
okay now what does that have to say
about the overall energy conservation
well when you do this branching you are
literally taking a pre-existing single
branch
and decomposing it into other branches
that are shorter right their amplitudes
are smaller
what matters is that number one the
total energy
of all the branches is a hundred percent
super duper conserved
all conserved quantities are 100
conserved in all the different branches
um and the sum of all the branches all
at once that's just
perfectly crystal clear but what's
interesting and sort of
understated when you discuss quantum
mechanics is
from inside any one branch you don't
see the other branches and you don't
know that the amplitude
of your own branch has shrunk you don't
know
that you are now part of a world
described by a smaller vector
right that has absolutely zero effect on
your
life so therefore you have to
distinguish between
the overall amount of stuff energy or
charge or whatever
in the way function of the universe
versus the amount that you
seem to witness in your branch so what
happens is your
contribution to the overall energy of
the universe gets less and less
as time goes on but you don't notice
because you're stuck within one branch
and to you the energy is approximately
conserved and the same thing works
with charge or anything like that for
the question about
information traveling faster than light
i'm not exactly sure what you're aiming
at i suspect that
you're imagining putting the other world
at some distance
that light would have to travel but
different branches of the wave function
are not at any distance from each other
there's no space in between them so
there's no need for information to
travel faster
than the speed of light you might be
aiming at something different but i
wasn't quite sure from the question
so joseph is asking about you know can a
world simultaneously split from more
than one trunk which is to say
can we start with um multiple smaller
vectors
and sort of add them together so
multiple branches of the wave function
combining in some sense and you know
i've talked about this before but the
practical answer is no that never ever
happens
but it's practical in the exact same
sense that you know entropy
on large scales does not spontaneously
go down
it's not that the probability is zero
there's a probability that could happen
but the probability is so absurdly
crazily tiny that there's zero chance
you need to worry about it okay so
in the real world branches increase in
number toward the future
not the past now the questions about the
double slit
and and uh two state systems versus
continuous systems i'm not sure i know
what is going on here um one thing that
i did say maybe this is answering the
double slit question
is the branching only happens when you
have decoherence
and again this is something that i think
is the right way to think about everett
not everyone does
you might get different answers from
different people the answer is to not
listen to anybody but me
when it comes to the many world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics in
my way of thinking about it
worlds is the world is the word
that we apply to branches of the wave
function that are entangled with
different states of the environment
not just different little vectors we add
together
we only count it as worlds when those
little vectors represent
different states of the environment so
if you have a single spin
then a superposition of spin up and spin
down that's not two worlds
right it couldn't be because there's
another
basis for the vector space in which is
only one direction in which it's
spinning
so the the question how many directions
is the superposition involving is not
even well defined
right um likewise for the double slit
experiment
the electron going through to through
those two slits
it is not decohered if it were you would
not see an interference pattern on the
other side then you would have measured
effectively where the electron is so
they're not
in two different branches they're in the
same branch of the wave function the two
different parts of the electron that go
through the two different slits
okay and finally jeff's question is one
i understand the least so i'm not going
to do a very good
job here maybe you're asking why is the
wave function expressed as a
superposition of positions rather than
momenta or something
like that and that is entirely a
question of convenience
i mean this is why going back earlier to
the mad dog epireadianism question
this is why i don't want to privilege
things like position or momentum because
there's multiple ways of expressing
the wave function and you're allowed to
use whatever way you want
you need to ask yourself what is most
useful what is most appropriate for the
circumstances that you're looking at
but then you say it seems equally
plausible that the detector would
measure
four points or a single point or a
circle shape or something like that and
now i'm not quite sure where you're
going
this is um i mean it's just a physics
question you shoot an electron
at a target oh maybe this is what you
mean okay so
um yeah let me read this question again
because you say the double slit
experiment but maybe
maybe as far as getting confused take a
you can make an electron gun
right you can take a gizmo that makes
electrons and shoots them at a screen
indeed you have tv sets just like that
um so the question might be
when an electron hits a screen why does
it make a dot
rather than some more complicated
pattern and that has nothing to do with
the double slit experiment the double
set experiment is an example of that but
is
usually used to illustrate other points
so if the question is why does the
electron make a dot
the answer is because physics is local
because
the way that the electron interacts
with the screen is local in space
so in other words this and that feeds
into what you mean by d coherence
remember i just said that d coherence
has this property that it puts it makes
branches of the wave function where
systems are
coherent in in their macroscopic
physical configuration
so the electron that's a wave will hit
the screen everywhere but it will
interact
individually with the different atoms on
the screen or molecules or whatever
and they will all either light up or not
but then when they light up they emit
light
and that light is then part of the
environment right i mean we can see it
and we can
interact with it other light particles
go away
so the wave function branches and the
wave function branches
separately into worlds that represent
which atom in the screen the electron
could have hit
because it becomes decoherent because
they emit light in different directions
so i guess that is a it is a confusing
point because it's a combination of the
underlying fundamental laws
that say that the electron interacts
locally with different
atoms that it could hit and the specific
features of decoherence that say that
you branch into worlds that are sort of
the same
in their environment and monitoring the
same macroscopic configurations for the
stuff in them
i hope that is some help okay trevor
villwock says after you hearing
mentioned emerson lake and palmer on a
previous episode i'm curious if you're
into any other prog rock
or other experimentally climbed music
like 20 and 21st century classical music
so part of why i um chose this question
as one to be answered i don't know
very deep answers uh so yes i was
especially like in my
uh college days very into progressive
rock
emerson lake and palmer yes genesis pink
floyd that kind of thing
um but yeah i drifted away a little bit
i still love listening to them
but i don't follow the modern versions
of them and they are related to like you
say
experimentally inclined music including
some classical music
and the reason why i'm answering the
question is just to sort of lament
that i don't follow music that much
anymore you know like i said when i was
in
college in grad school i was really into
the progressive rock thing
when i was uh a young professor in
chicago
you know chicago is just a great music
town overall and i in particular got
i was always into jazz also but i really
got to be able to go to see live jazz in
chicago in a way that was just an
embarrassment of riches there was so
much good stuff going on
patricia barber von freeman ken
vandermark people like that
um and here in la both you know i'm
older settled down
married have cats but also you know the
music scene is different
here in l.a and you know there's lots of
strivers trying to become rock stars but
there's not as many
uh people playing every tuesday night at
11 p.m
in a jazz club with with 20 people in
the audience right that's just not the
scene around here at least
so i don't know of that scene anyway i'm
sure there's wonderful music going on
around here in la but i'm sort of past
that part of my
uh music loving career so i become stead
and predictable
when it comes to my music like many
middle-aged people i like the music that
i grew up with right and
and that's terrible and i feel bad about
it but you know so be it
um in my spare time to do new and
interesting things
trying to learn new parts of science and
philosophy and things like that i hate
to say it that makes me sound very
boring but
um i mean obviously i do things purely
for fun also
like that's why you've been subjected to
podcasts about basketball and poker and
things like that but i'm not following
the music scene as much as i should
sorry about that eamonn mcgee says
if the universe was in a more dense
state
in its early stages would time have
passed differently
for atoms quarks neutrons in the early
universe than the present day universe
no the short answer is no um
you know again it depends on what you
mean what do you mean if time had passed
differently
uh time always moves at one second per
second go back to the
ama last month and i gave a little pep
talk about this in the beginning
it's just confusing and wrong for people
to talk about time traveling at
different rates
what you are allowed to talk about is
the elapsed time being different for two
different
trajectories in space time that both
begin at the same point and end at the
same point okay
so if you somehow i don't know how you
could do this but if you could take a
little
clock and attach it to an atom in the
early universe
it would the atom would see the clock
moving completely normally no matter
what the two of them were doing together
if you took did that to two little atoms
and they went on different paths and
came back
then they might read slightly different
times
but that's nothing special about the
early universe that's just because atoms
are moving near the speed of light
atoms are more generally particles right
the rule of thumb
is when the temperature of the universe
is larger than the mass of the particle
in natural units
uh then particles are probably moving
near the speed of light that's kind of
what it means
right to have a temperature above the
mass of a particle means that
the energy is the tip the average energy
per particle
is greater than the particle's mass so
most of its energy is coming from
kinetic energy coming from motion
and that means it's moving near the
speed of light to get more kinetic
energy
than rest energy you need to be moving
close to the speed of light so anyway
yeah like if you think about individual
particles moving near the speed of light
they will
experience different amounts of time but
maybe you mean
you could take the collection of all the
particles right that's a plasma
or a gas or whatever depending on
exactly what epoch you're thinking of
and there is a rest frame for the plasma
which is different than the rest frame
of any of the individual particles just
like the atoms in the air you're
breathing
they have individual motions but they're
still an average velocity
of the air which hopefully is small in
the room where you're breathing it
and so you could say well what about
that what about
time as measured in that rest frame and
you might ask
so this i wasn't sure what you were
getting at you might ask well because
the universe was so
dense gravity is more important and
therefore
is gravity affecting the passage of time
in the early universe
right so again the answer is no it's
really not affecting it at all
so and again there's subtleties here
one subtlety is again even if there were
a gravitational field like even if
you're near a black hole
that's when there's a strong
gravitational field okay and that's
where there is a
strong time dilation effect but the way
to think about that effect
is not time's moving faster or slower
it's how do you compare
the elapsed time if you go near the
black hole to what you would have or
what your friend experiences when
they're staying far away
and it's much like the twin paradox if
you go near a black hole
hang out there for a while and come back
you will have experienced
less time than the people who just
stayed behind
so you might think that since the early
universe
is very very dense and gravity is strong
it is kind of like that
but it's not why because everyone
in the early universe is experiencing
the same gravitational field there's no
analog of your friend far away
the early universe is uniform right the
early universe is a plasma which is the
same density
everywhere this is one of the features
of cosmology that makes it very doable
is that the universe is more or less
homogeneous and isotropic and was even
more homogeneous at early times
so and that's not just a technicality
literally all the clocks that were in
the rest frame of the plasma of the
early universe ticked at one second per
second and when we say
you know when we say the era one second
after the big bang
that's what we mean we mean time as
measured by
clocks that are in the rest frame of the
plasma of the early universe
so that really is one second after the
big bang there's not some other number
of seconds that you really should be
using
we're telling you the right answer there
okay gumberto nani says
for cosmologists from planets located in
the remote future
those who live in galaxies getting away
faster than light from all the other
galaxies are they condemned
to think their galaxy is all of the
universe or is there something being
printed in the fabric of space or in the
last scattering surface that can tell
them how to know more
well there is uh sort of what happens is
is a good question
you know our universe is expanding and
also accelerating so let's imagine that
the acceleration continues forever
that's the easiest thing to imagine the
most probable thing is true
it might not be true but let's imagine
that's what true that's what's true okay
so galaxies that we see today
if you did the dumbest thing if you
forgot that there's relativity and you
just said well
the galaxy the universe is expanding and
the galaxies are moving away from us and
so
at any one moment in time there is a
distance to the galaxy
and there's a sort of rate at which the
universe is expanding so i can figure
out an apparent velocity and it will
eventually become greater than the speed
of light
all that is true but what is really
relevant is
the galaxy is emitting light toward us
right
and the light is becoming more and more
redshifted
so just like something falling into a
black hole
the light from that thing becomes more
and more redshifted and there is a
moment
that is the last moment in the history
of that object that we
outside observers will ever see the same
thing is true
for galaxies that are being accelerated
away from us cosmologically
they will get redder and redder and we
will get less and less information from
them and there is a point in their
evolution locally from their point of
view
that we will never see because the light
just never gets to us
so but it's more than that because not
only do the individual photons we see
from those galaxies become red
we see fewer and fewer photons right if
you're emitting a certain number of
photons
per second in your rest frame there's
more and more
time in between those photons from our
rest frame
so not only do the galaxies get redder
and redder they get dimmer and dimmer
and there is less less information to be
received from them
the same thing is true for the cosmic
microwave background it continues to be
redshifted
right now the typical wavelength is i
don't know millimeters or centimeters
for
uh cnb radiation it's going to grow
longer and longer eventually it will be
miles
or kilometers or parsecs or mega parsecs
or billions of light years if you wait
long enough
so if you really do wait long enough
all the other stuff in the universe will
fade away and it'll become invisible
and will those people be able to guess
or hypothesize that they came from
a bright shiny universe like we live in
today
i don't know i do think there's a point
in principle
where it becomes very very very hard to
do but again i'm not very good at
predicting
future technology so i'll be silent
about that
david dicloud says do we only need many
worlds because our consciousness doesn't
observe superposition or are there other
reasons unrelated to consciousness
why we can't just assume there is a
single world which is forever in
superposition and just more and more
entangled
um so i think that you make a slight uh
hypothesis contrary to fact there where
you say we can't just assume there is a
single world
forever in superposition that is exactly
whatever it says
there is a single wave function of the
universe
which is forever in superposition and is
more and more entangled
but within that wave function we are
allowed to
describe it as multiple non-interacting
worlds
that has nothing to do with
consciousness nothing
nothing in quantum mechanics has
anything to do with consciousness the
only
time that words like consciousness or
awareness or agency should come into
discussions of quantum mechanics
is when you are specifically trying to
just to describe
what conscious agents see if you don't
want to then you don't ever need to
use those words okay but you still would
have branching of the wave function
to the extent that it would be possible
and helpful to break up
the wave function of the universe into
individual branches that evolve
independently
that's something you're allowed to do it
is precisely the same
as saying that if you were laplace's
demon you could discuss
all of the molecules in a box of gas
individually you know their positions
and momenta therefore you don't
need to use words like temperature or
entropy
that doesn't mean you're not allowed to
use words like temperature and entropy
you can calculate them
and likewise if there were no conscious
creatures in the universe you could
still figure out what the branches are
and when they were happening
but you wouldn't need to if you had
infinite information but none of us does
that's the way the dynamic goes
gordon bamber says if gravity were a
repulsive force instead of attractive
how would this affect the arrow of time
so the zeroth order answer here is not
at all
there's no direct connection there um
the reason why i bring it up is just to
mention an interesting paper
that i don't think is right i don't
agree with it but it's i could be wrong
and it's an interesting paper it was by
um brian greene
previous mindscape guest and kurt
hinderbrickler and some other people
back in the day a few years ago where
they said
look what we're trying to explain when
it comes to the arrow of time
what we need to explain is why the early
universe had low entropy after that most
of it
follows roughly speaking and if it
weren't for gravity
the state of the early universe famously
looks like it's high entropy
right it looks like a thermal gas it
looks like a very hot dense
um collection of particles so we
there's this song and dance when it
comes to gravity and entropy in the
early universe where you say
well the early universe looks high
entropy except for gravity but gravity
is there so it's really low entropy et
cetera so what brian and curtin friends
said
was what if you turned off gravity
in the early universe what if for some
reason gravity were zero
at early times and then everything would
equilibrate right you would naturally
in a box of gas you would go to a high
entropy configuration
but then somehow gravity turns on okay
and then the universe starts expanding
and
becoming crumpled etc etc so in other
words
maybe the early universe was high
entropy
given its conditions at the time so for
reasons i'm not going to go into now i
don't think that quite works
as a cosmological scenario but i do
think there's a relationship between
gravity and the arrow of time
very broadly speaking it's not that it's
repulsive versus attractive and that
would change things in any obvious way
but they are potentially related somehow
okay
gregory mendel i presume you're not the
guy with the peapods who discovered
heredity but gregory says
what is what if in the schrodinger's cat
scenario we replace
nuclear decay with measuring the spin
flip in nuclear magnetic resonance
so the probability of triggering the
position oscillates between zero and one
if we let a cycle go by so there was a
time when it is 100 likely the poison
was triggered
but wait until the next zero percent
probability and open the box what do we
observe
and i've edited out a little bit but i
think gregory you figured out your own
question here because
of course the point is
that you can have a quantum system
that evolves slowly smoothly you know
from one state to another
that's fine and that's perfectly
reversible
but what the whole point of the
schrodinger's cat scenario
is to let that quantum system interact
with a big messy macroscopic world and
once that happens your dynamics is
irreversible
so even if it's in nuclear decay or
sorry a nuclear magnetic resonance or
something like that
if you're observing the phase
of the nucleus okay then what that means
is you are coupling the phase of the
nucleus to something big and macroscopic
like a detector and the detector
once it clicks or doesn't click that
makes a macroscopic
alteration of the environment and that
is not going to be undone by waiting
around
longer so the question is not what is
the dynamics of the system you're
observing
the question is does that system become
entangled with the wider world and once
it does
it's done no going back once that
decoherence happens it's irreversible
an anonymous questioner says would early
universe physicists have had
trouble guessing any part of the
standard model for example
would they have would have been obvious
that one day fermions would gain mass if
the lab couldn't produce temperatures
cool enough to break electric weak age
symmetry
so the point here is the the the the
background is we have the higgs boson
the higgs boson uh at early times
had a zero expectation value in the
universe that is to say the average
value of the higgs field at any one
point in space
was zero it could fluctuate a little bit
around that but basically it was zero
and then eventually the universe cooled
down to a point where we underwent what
is called the electroweak phase
transition
and now the higgs flops down from zero
to some non-zero value
and it's that non-zero value of the
higgs field in empty space that gives
mass to elementary
particles to fermions and w bosons and
things like that
so if you were a physicist if you
somehow a very heat resistant physicist
in the very early universe
could you have known that was going to
happen um
in principle yes you could have known
that was going to happen so what you
would have to do
in fact we kind of do something like
this so what you'd have to do is measure
all the parameters in your theory
and then trust your theory right so the
parameters in your theory include all
the different
couplings of the higgs boson to itself
as well as to other particles
and then you can ask yourself are there
what are the dynamics of the field in
very different circumstances like you
have the equations just a matter of your
ability to solve them
and we do that now we ask whether or not
there are
other values that higgs boson could have
um that under different circumstances
maybe even in the future
right maybe our higgs boson value could
spontaneously tunnel to a different
value we don't know
um so yes i think you know there's a lot
of thought experimenting going into
imagining these early universe
physicists but in principle
they could figure it out now your
question technically was would they have
had trouble
guessing it maybe yes it's very possible
they would have had trouble
guessing that uh you know the the um
electroweak phase transition is earlier
it's at higher temperature
than the qcd phase transition so back
then
before you had the higgs boson with his
expectation value you didn't have
uh protons and neutrons either you just
had free quarks and gluons it had been a
very very different universe in very
various ways i would ask could they have
figured out
that quarks would eventually become
confined that's a good question
again in principle they could have but
it might have been hard
andrew vernon smith says in an interview
you had with kip thorne kip referred to
certain parts of the movie interstellar
as crossing the line into impossible
science fiction
could you elaborate on what the evidence
that kip was relying on
that proves or tends to prove the
impossibility of those parts of the
movie
um i'm pretty sure he was just referring
to the end of the movie
you know uh i only vaguely remember it
now but there's that
thing where he goes in the library and
he's like poking and sending signals and
there's time travel and things like that
and
all of these were inspired by ideas
from modern physics but none of it none
of that library stuff
actually could be happening in known
laws of physics
none of the interactions the poking of
books and things like that that's not
physics okay that's just imagination
that's just fantasy
so i think both kip and for that matter
jonah nolan who is
technically the screenwriter on the
movie brother of christopher nolan
uh are like we don't know what's
happening and that was the
mind of christopher nolan sort of
imagined this scenario again
inspired by physics but not actually
following it that's what i think he had
in mind
all the stuff with the black hole in the
wormhole and stuff like that that stuff
was pretty scientifically
respectable scott says
if something like the ads cft
correspondence is shown to apply to our
universe
would that lead you to believe that all
of our math and physics are convenient
descriptions that
don't necessarily have any fundamental
reality
uh nope it would not so i have
uh you know i think you have to
be a little bit careful about
what it means to have fundamental
reality right versus being a convenient
description
convenient descriptions are only
convenient if they capture some
fundamental reality
right so i think the tables and chairs
are convenient descriptions
they are nowhere to be found in the
standard model of particle physics right
they're higher level emergent phenomena
but at the level of everyday life
they're very very convenient
to describe what the world around us is
likewise
all of our math and physics clearly
captures something real
about reality and that i don't know
whether you want to call it fundamental
or not but it's real
okay it's both a convenient description
and
real i don't think that you should
distinguish between convenient
descriptions and fundamental
reality now there are descriptions that
are
false right you know you could be wrong
about something when someone does a card
trick and they're tricking you and they
pull a rabbit out of a hat
they might lead you to believe something
that was false now that's
not reality okay so it's not like
everything you see is obviously
truly reality but the physics
descriptions that really do capture some
element of what is happening around us
even if they capture it in an indirect
way
are things that i would still count as
part of fundamental reality
i'm going to group two equate to two two
equations
two questions together here nate says in
many worlds we assume that the world we
interact with is
a branch of some universal wave function
do you know of any ways to describe
what we think of as causality or
locality within the context of our
branch
on the scale of this universal wave
function and if so what
are they and then keith says in the
semi-classical gravity of hawking
radiation
what is the classical part so i'm
grouping these together because
they both get at a slightly thorny but
not completely incomprehensible issue
which is
how the classical limit arises
in quantum mechanics so keith says what
is the classical part in
when we say semi-classical gravity
that's the easy one
semi-classical gravity is just classical
gravity classical general relativity
right classical
space time but quantum fields on top
of that classical space time so the
quantum fields on top of the classical
space-time
can even include quantized fluctuations
in the gravitational field
so gravitons and things like that that's
why it's semi-classical gravity
quantum mechanics on top of a classical
space-time
and to go back to nate's question
we have the story that we tell in many
worlds about branching
decoherence all that stuff right
and what i said earlier was that these
branches
have the feature that they sort of
pick out special pointer states
which are coherently arranged in
physical space
they have macroscopic shapes and sizes
and locations okay
whereas if you have a superposition of
two things with different
locations or shapes or whatever they
would decohere
right away uh the things that persist as
long-lived robust states are those that
sort of look
classical right now that
is a very
when you say that out loud you probably
say oh okay that kind of makes sense
right but it actually requires a lot of
work and thought to show
that that is what is going on i mean
this paper i recently wrote
with ashmit singh recently might be like
last year yeah last year so it was still
pretty recent it got published recently
um called quantum muriology so we asked
the question
given this big hilbert space how do you
divide it up
into subspaces like an environment and a
system
for example and what we suggested was
that what we're doing is looking for
classical behavior
why are we looking for classical
behavior well you know maybe
anthropic reasons or maybe some of the
non-anthropic reasons that have to do
with algorithmic compressibility or
simplicity or robustness i don't know
exactly but who cares
what we said was let's look for
classical behavior let's ask how we
divide up
hilbert space into subsystems so as to
get classical behavior and what we found
is
there's actually two aspects to
classical behavior one is
the the thing that you're looking at you
know the baseball or whatever
it follows a classical trajectory and it
doesn't spread out all over the place
right if you launch a rocket toward the
moon
you don't need quantum mechanics to get
it there it will more or less move on
its classical newtonian trajectory
and the other one is that you're in a
pointer state in other words the state
that is described by the branch that
you're on
is one that doesn't keep getting
entangled this entanglement remains
almost
constant and these two different
criteria of
remaining localized along a classical
trajectory
and remaining unentangled with the
environment they're different sounding
but they
play together there's some relationship
between them and it's subtle and
we're still thinking about it so we
think that this underlies
why there is a difference in the
observed world between positions and
momenta for example
but i think this is part of a story that
we don't actually have completely
explicated yet um but the short answer
to your actual question is
the way that the universe branches
in many worlds is onto branches that
individually
act as classical as they can
sometimes they're not going to act
classical there's a geiger counter right
we measure a spin or whatever
but that's an incredibly tiny amount of
quantum behavior compared to what we do
in our everyday lives and so
that feature is not just an accident
that's kind of what defines the branches
that we're on this emerging classicality
and once you get that
you get causality and locality and all
that stuff coming just as much
along for the ride as it would in
ordinary classical mechanics
robin quinnell says is there any physics
evidence that we are in a simulation
nope there is not in fact i would argue
that there is evidence that we're not in
a simulation so what do you mean by
evidence in this case
you got to be a good bayesian you have
to ask yourself what would we expect the
universe to look like were we in a
simulation
versus what we'd expect to look like if
we were not in a simulation now
that's a really hard question to answer
it's very analogous to asking the
relevant the analogous question about
god
right what would he expect the universe
to look like if god existed versus
purely naturalism
well it depends on your idea about god
it depends on your idea about the
simulators and what they're trying to do
with the simulation
but what we can tell about our universe
is number one that it's
super wasteful of resources right like
if what they
care about is us
like if you thought that the simulators
care about human beings in any way
then they've made an awfully big
universe most of which we can never get
to
um and most of which has no effect on us
so
you would think again it's not a
necessary
uh consequence but if you were to guess
let's put it this way if you did notice
yeah this is a good way to put it right
okay so you have two
scenarios on the table one is just
reality
naturalism there's universe nobody's
laws of physics the other is we live in
a simulation okay
and there's two options one and it's
sort of two
pictures of the universe which we can on
broad uh principles distinguish
a big universe where there's us but then
we're very very tiny compared to the
bigger picture and there's lots of
galaxies and so forth that seems very
wasteful
and resource intensive that we have
nothing to do with
or there's a small universe right like
that the universe as a whole
is more or less human scaled maybe it's
you know a million times the size of a
human being rather than billions and
billions of times the size of a human
being what would you expect
under these two scenarios of naturalism
versus
simulation well here's what i would say
if
we did live in the tiny universe
then you might say aha that makes
perfect sense to me because we probably
live in a simulation
right that makes more sense to me if we
live in a simulation that the universe
is human size that the universe is
sort of adapted to our existence here
and
if you're gonna say that if you would
believe that if you think that
counterfactually
were the universe tiny we would take
that as evidence for a simulation
then it follows logically and you cannot
wriggle out of it
that if the universe is large you must
take that as evidence against
the idea that we live in a simulation of
course you can wriggle out of it you can
say well they're very
you know technologically advanced they
don't care about resources they're using
very clever
optimization algorithms whatever but if
you think that we would take it as
evidence for
simulation where the universe to be
small then we should take it as evidence
against simulation that the universe is
large
okay maya apple says would it be
possible to be fully certain in the
finality of a theory of everything
isn't it always possible for there to be
a different underlying explanatory
system
uh sure yeah i don't think that
certainty
is ever your goal in science at all
because even if you had a theory of
everything that fit
all of the data perfectly you could
always do an experiment tomorrow that
didn't fit the data and you would have
to change it
right so this is part of being a
scientist we don't aim towards
certainty we aim towards higher and
higher credences
but it's always a mistake to think that
you know we're getting to
100 belief in our theories because that
would be bad
that would mean we could never change
our minds in the future that's not how
scientists
should work okay the final question is
jim murphy
says the universe is really big to me
this is distressing i don't know if this
relates to the simulation argument
whatsoever
but he says to me this is distressing
not because i'm afraid of how small we
are but because of a kind of cosmic fomo
for those of us who are too old fomo is
the kid's way of saying
fear of missing out fomo the
disappointment of knowing that there is
so much out there that we will never
discover
is sometimes too much to handle do you
ever get these feelings and how do you
remind yourself that there is plenty to
explore
here on earth um so this is the final
question so we can be a little bit
uh relaxed about it you know i don't get
those feelings
those are not the feelings i get um in
fact the opposite like
what if we were almost done what if we
had almost discovered
or did discover had discovered
everything interesting to be discovered
about physics politics economics
whatever chemistry biology
what if we basically knew everything i
don't that would be terrible like that
would be
i'm sure that we would think of ways to
keep ourselves interested and amused etc
but the fact that we live in a universe
where there are so many things yet to be
discovered
uh makes me happy well especially
because we have discovered a bunch of
things right like
my perspective is obviously highly
parochial and limited
because i don't know what things are
going to be like a thousand or a million
years from now
but in some way of thinking we live in a
pretty good part of intellectual history
where we've learned a lot enough that uh
you know there's not a lot of child
mortality etc we can go much farther
getting rid of poverty and disease and
curing aging and things like that so i
think that probably
unless we do something dumb a hundred or
two hundred or a thousand years from now
will be better
than now but over historical time scales
comparing us now
to a hundred thousand years ago we're
doing a lot better now
but there's still a lot to be discovered
right right here on earth
and so i do not have any of this fear of
missing out like i i don't even
even in much more uh down to earth
circumstances
fear of missing out is not something i
have
uh it's not even something that makes
sense to me because
there's the question is not what are you
missing the question
is what are you experiencing right as
long as you are experiencing all sorts
of good stuff
the fact that there's other good stuff
that you're not experiencing
is just something i couldn't even
imagine caring too much
about right if it's literally something
that i could go and experience and it
would be even better
then fine but then i'll be missing out
on the other thing that i'm that i'm
getting now so
sure you should work to sort of have an
interesting portfolio of experiences
that sounds like a very reasonable uh
attainable goal
but to experience everything to learn
everything to do everything like
no and i have no interest in even trying
to do that
it's about the journey right we are
these little tiny bits of uh
self-organization that feed off of the
free energy around
us for a finite period of time in a very
finite world of experience
but that world of experience is still
way larger than we have the ability
to experience so i'm not worried about
all the experiences i can't have
i got enough to worry about with the
experiences i do have
all right thanks for sticking with me i
can feel the voice beginning to go
uh thanks for supporting mindscape as
always it's been tough times we're
i'm getting vaccinated tomorrow i get my
second shot as i'm recording this
so i'm very happy about that hope
everyone out there is getting vaccinated
if not already then very soon um again
i hope that the podcast has been
a little bit useful to folks in these
weird times of hours and it's certainly
been extremely wonderful for me to have
so much support from you out there
for mindscape and i look forward to what
it has coming up in the future all right
take care bye
you